Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So.
Moin, Leute.
Naja, moin ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
12.40 Uhr.
Omega-Lul.
Ich hab mich grad so brutal vollgefressen, ey.
Muss jetzt gucken, dass ich nicht einpenne.
Aber das ist okay.
Weil laut meiner Garmin-Uhr
hab ich heute...
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Zack.
Ich guck nach.
Ich hab heute...
Hä?
Wo steht's denn?
total calories burned.
Kalorien hab ich verbraucht heute.
Heute war aber auch echt brutal, ne?
Also...
Manchmal
ist eine Woche.
Ich habe hier so einen automatisch generierten
Trainingsplan von Garmin.
Kann man mit der App sich erzeugen.
Und
manche Wochen ist das
wirklich easy.
Überhaupt kein großes Ding.
Hauptsächlich irgendwie 46 Minuten
Base-Ausdauer, langsam rennen, alles gut.
Aber diese Woche, ey,
diese Woche willst du es echt wissen.
Ich musste jetzt, man sieht das hier
ganz gut in den Charts, also ihr seht das nicht,
aber ich sehe das.
Ich musste heute 10 Minuten einlaufen.
Hier sieht man es ganz gut.
10 Minuten einlaufen, dann 19 Minuten schnell laufen.
5 Minuten langsam gehen.
Wieder 19 Minuten schnell laufen.
Und dann habe ich noch irgendwie so 13, 14 Minuten mich ausgelaufen.
Alter, das war echt brutal.
Ich war fertig danach.
Ich habe das die Woche über schon probiert, weil eigentlich wäre diese Trainingseinheit heute gar nicht dran gewesen.
Ich habe das die Woche über schon zweimal probiert, aber ich habe es nicht durchgehalten, weil es war zu heiß.
Leute, es ist einfach ein Unterschied, ob man bei 25 Grad sich anstrengt oder bei 37 Grad.
Alfred, danke schön für den Sub.
Das ist echt ein Riesenunterschied.
Bei 37 Grad kannst du komplett knicken.
So.
Ich glaube, ich muss mal meine VM einschalten.
Ne, Blödsinn.
Ich muss nicht die VM einschalten.
Ich muss mein Mini-PC einschalten.
Jawoll.
Start.
Starte das verdammte Spiel.
Nee, aber das war halt wirklich brutal, ey.
Also 19, ich sag euch,
19 Minuten schnell
rennen, also zweimal 19 Minuten
schnell rennen, das ist wirklich heftig.
Und da hast du nur 5 Minuten Pause dazwischen.
Also das ist wirklich heftig.
Das ist auch deutlich, deutlich länger, als man 5 Kilometer braucht.
Also das ist schon wirklich brutal gewesen diesmal.
So, ich muss mal kurz die Tastatur umstöpseln.
Zack, hallo?
Wollte gerade sagen, warum ist denn jetzt das ausgegangen?
So.
Mal checken, ob das jetzt funzt.
Jawoll.
Oh, ich muss meine Logitech-Software starten.
Hallo? Logitech?
Gehub?
Warum ist der Gehub eigentlich so langsam?
Ist das mal ernsthaft?
Warum ist diese Software so übertrieben langsam?
Kennt ihr noch den alten Logitech-Treiber?
der sah vielleicht nicht so fancy aus, ja?
Aber den hast du gestartet in
keine Ahnung, 80 Millisekunden
und dann war das Ding einfach am Start.
Das hat es überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Oli, dankeschön für den Sub.
Pog Subscription, ihr beide hier.
Huge. Das ist ja quasi
schon.
Starten wir erstmal unseren Krempel.
Starten wir den hier
Zack, starten wir unser Terminal
Zack, dann starten wir Proxmox
Brauchen wir jetzt bestimmt, hab ich das noch an?
Hab ich das vergessen auszutun?
Ne, mein Browser
Chebated mich einfach
Wollte grad sagen, ich hab das Ding noch ausgeschaltet
Das wär mal ultra low power, oder?
0,1 Watt
Zieht das Ding gerade angeblich
Im ausgeschalteten Zustand
So
Das da und jetzt brauchen wir noch
Ein Private Window
Für
Für setservers.com
Oh, da muss ich mich jetzt einloggen
Da müsst ihr gleich wieder weggucken, Chat
Top Secret
Proxmox-Konsole?
Was hab ich da alles noch für Müll auf, ey
Da müsst ihr gleich wieder weggucken
Aber vorher schwätzen wir erst nochmal ein bisschen
Ich muss erstmal hier in Linux-Bastelstimmung kommen.
Ich muss übrigens, was mir jetzt gerade wieder beim Stream einfällt, ich habe doch letztens hier Sellout gemacht, Seagate, Ukraine, Alternate, Sponsoring und ich habe denen noch gar nicht den abschließenden Report und Rechnung geschickt.
Jetzt habe ich schon Sellout gemacht und habe noch nicht mal Geld dafür gekriegt bis jetzt.
Das muss ich mal machen.
Ich bin so faul, was solche Sachen angeht, Leute.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Kennt ihr die Geschichte mit?
Also vielleicht kennt ihr das bei euch auch.
Wenn ihr immer so denkt,
ah, heute habe ich da keinen Bock drauf,
machst du einfach beim nächsten Stream.
Oder machst du da einfach bei nächster Gelegenheit.
Und bei nächster Gelegenheit denkt ihr dann,
ah, da habe ich heute eigentlich auch keinen Bock drauf.
Ich mache es dann bei nächster Gelegenheit.
Und so, das ist, ich meine,
Wir hatten, das Sponsoring ging glaube ich bis
Bis
8. Juli oder so
Das ist schon fast
Ein Monat wieder vorbei
Wenn ich da keine Rechnung schreibe
Ist das richtig brutal
Pepo burn money
Haben die denn
Für Mac einen offiziellen Logitech Treiber
Wie ist das
Also Treiber ist ja immer ein blödes Wort dafür
Letztendlich
Das ist ja nicht wirklich
Das ist halt irgendein Frontend
Für Treiberfunktionalität
Ich weiß nicht, wie ist das auf dem Mac
Ist das offiziell von Logitech
Oder
Ist das so ein Third-Party-Ding
Wie es auch für Linux gibt
Wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte
Dass wahrscheinlich diese Third-Party-Sachen
Für die Logitech-Hardware unter Linux
Sogar besser funktionieren
als unter Windows.
Logitech offiziell.
Ja, dann ist es aber ziemlich mies.
Ich hatte gerade auf meinem
Vorschau-Rechner,
also ich habe hier quasi hier neben dem da,
hier wo bei euch der Bildschirmrand hier links aufhört,
steht der zweite Monitor.
Da habe ich hier Stream-Vorschau und Chat und
Notes und alles mögliche.
Und den habe ich gerade eingeschaltet
und er ist
hier mal
gefreezt. Bei Booten.
Also bevor er richtig angefangen hat zu booten.
Der ist sogar im BIOS gefreezt.
Hab ich schon gedacht, oh shit, was jetzt?
Dann hab ich aber komplett ausgeschaltet
am Netzteil.
Ein paar Sekunden gewartet, wieder eingeschaltet.
Dann ist er wieder gefreezt. Dann hab ich
zwei Minuten nix gemacht. Und dann ist er auf einmal
ins Booten geswitcht.
Also an ein Passwort eingegeben.
Booten geswitcht. Also keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht gibt der Vorschau-Rechner...
Oh, da muss ich mal gucken. Wie viel RAM
ist da eigentlich drin? Eine Sekunde.
Sekunde, Sekunde.
Performance.
32 GB RAM.
Chat, wisst ihr, ob man irgendwo in diesem Windows Task Manager sieht, was man für einen RAM verbaut hat?
Sieht man das hier irgendwo?
Ach hier, guck.
4.800 sieht man hier.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was ich in dem anderen PC hier habe.
Das steht da gar nicht
Hab ich da
Speed, 3200
Das ist DDR4, oder?
3200, oder, Jetgear?
Das hier ist DDR5
Okay, da hab ich noch 32 Schick DDR4
In meinem anderen Rechner
Schade, dass mein NAS keine DDR4-Rammriegel frisst
Ich muss mal überlegen, was habe ich denn für einen Rechner davor gehabt
War das vielleicht auch schon DDR4?
Was hatte ich denn davor für einen?
Ich hatte den hier, den, den
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Max, FPS-PC.
Ich habe doch da bestimmt ein Video drüber gemacht.
2022?
Ah, nee.
Das andere ist zu alt.
Ich meine, ich habe ja den aktuellen PC 2022 gekauft.
Der andere davor, der war fünf Jahre...
Das war dann noch DDR3 oder so davor.
Nee, das bringt nichts.
Wie hast du das denn hingekriegt?
Ach, aus dem Mitarbeiter-Store.
Arbeitest du bei Dell?
Oder ist das so ein
Corporate Benefits
Store, wo du dir Sennheiser Kopfhörer
und Gedöns kaufen kannst?
Weil wenn das so ist, dann haben wir
das auch und dann ist das ein guter
Hinweis, das muss ich mir
nämlich mal aufschreiben
Mitarbeiter
Store
RAM und SSD
Da muss ich tatsächlich bei uns auch mal gucken
Es sei denn, wenn du jetzt bei Dell arbeitest, dann ist
wieder was anderes. Dann haben wir das natürlich nicht.
McFly,
danke schon für den Sub. Huge
Subscriber.
Wo ist eigentlich der
Michael? 50 Billiarden, schon lang nicht mehr gesehen.
So, erstmal Updates machen.
Fällt mir nur
gerade so auf. Was hat er hier für Schmerzen?
Pulsauto ist immer noch newer.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Es gibt Unternehmen, die ihre alten
Festplatten verkaufen.
Äh, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Ich glaube nicht, dass er das damit gemeint hat.
Aber ja, es gibt Unternehmen, die ihre alten Festplatten und alten SSDs verkaufen.
Das Problem dabei ist nur, dass sie die seltenen Mitarbeiter verkaufen,
sondern dass sie Verträge haben mit irgendwelchen Hardware...
Wie nennt man das so?
Hardware...
Wie heißt denn sowas?
die so gebrauchten Kram halt abnehmen.
Die Föbischer, irgendwie sowas, ja.
Also beim jetzigen Arbeitgeber
weiß ich es nicht. Beim alten Arbeitgeber
war das so, die haben, ich glaube
an Bechtle, das gibt es, oder?
Bechtle,
alte Hardware?
Wie heißen die, Bechtle?
Irgendwie sowas.
an die haben die ihre alte Hardware verkauft
und ich weiß noch, ich hab damals
ein paar mal gefragt, sag mal die alten
Notebooks sind doch richtig gut
bevor ihr die für ein Appel und ein Ei
irgendwie an Bechtle da
verscherbelt, dann
verkauft die doch mir, ich bezahle euch auch mehr, aber das ging nicht
weil die da irgendwelche Verträge haben, keine Chance
und das waren richtig gute
Notebooks, das war noch, also das ist schon eine ganze
Weile her, das war noch IBM
Thinkpad
51 oder irgendwie sowas
Nee, oder keine Ahnung.
Das war noch Z, wie heißen die Dinger?
T, T, T.
Gibt es T51?
Nee.
T.
T42?
Irgendwie sowas.
Das war noch, das war noch welche, die hatten so, ich weiß nicht, ob das sowas war.
Die hatten noch Metallscharniere und sowas.
Ja, ja, ja, hier, guck mal, sowas in der Richtung.
Die hatten noch, ihr seht ja das da hinten.
Guck mal, die hatten noch geile Auflösung hier.
Tausend mal tausend.
Beste.
Also, das Bild hat eindeutig, Leute, ich weiß nicht, ob euch das klar ist, aber so sehen Bilder mit Native 1000x1000 Auflösung eindeutig aus.
In Wirklichkeit war das mal eine 320x240 oder sowas.
So, aber guckt, die hatten noch Metallscharniere, die waren richtig nice.
Nice, hu.
Genau, hier mit Metallscharnieren.
Und bei den noch älteren, wir hatten jahrelang so ein ganz ganz altes im Schrank liegen, das hatte noch Xubuntu 8.10 drauf. Gibt es das überhaupt noch? Xubuntu 8.10. Also sprich 2008 Oktober, ne warte mal, August, September, Oktober, ja.
8 subuntu 8.10 war da noch drauf also ja noch älter das noch fetteres jahrzehntelang im schrank
liegen quasi auf der alten arbeit das ding war das war wirklich massive also damit damit konntest du
eindringlinge abwehren vielleicht bräuchten sie das in spanien auch gerade alle verhaltene bm notebooks
Ja genau mit diesem
Roten Trackpoint
Die waren echt geil
Die alten Notebooks
Verwendest du eigentlich auch Linux
Als zuerst auf der Arbeit
Ja ich verwende Linux auf der Arbeit
Aber das muss ich ein bisschen ausführen
Also auf der letzten Arbeit
das ist aber auch mittlerweile schon über drei Jahre her, dreieinhalb Jahre her,
auf der alten Arbeit hatte ich ein Notebook mit Manjaro Linux drauf.
Eine ganze Weile.
Bis zum Schluss hatte ich da einen Linux Notebook.
Das war ein, also früher war das immer IBM, war das also IBM bzw. Lenovo Notebooks.
und das letzte Notebook, was ich auf der alten Arbeit hatte, war ein Microsoft Surface Book oder irgendwie sowas.
Das lief mit Ubuntu aber echt erstaunlich gut.
Das einzige Problem, was das Ding hatte, dass du im Grub noch keine USB-Tastatur-Unterstützung hattest damals mit diesen Surface Books.
Deswegen musste man dann immer sein Encryption Secret über die Onboard-Tastatur angeben.
Aber das war es jetzt nicht so wild. Danach ging USB, Keyboard. Also da hatte ich quasi 18 Jahre oder so, nee, warte mal, 2007, 15 Jahre hatte ich da ein Linux-Notebook. Ich hatte sogar einen Linux-Desktop-Rechner am Anfang noch.
Also alles top.
Bei meinem neuen Arbeitgeber ist es tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter.
Da bist du gezwungen, auch wenn es echt krasser Paints-Champ ist, Leute.
Da bist du gezwungen, ein Windows-Notebook zu verwenden.
Es ist irgendein Dell oder HP.
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau, was das ist.
Dell oder HP ist das.
Notebook.
Und da ist Windows drauf installiert.
Und Leute, ich sag euch, das ist so zugemüllt, dieses Windows, Alter. WTF? Das ist so zugemüllt. Als ich das Notebook das erste Mal aufgemacht hab, da gab es noch, könnt ihr euch noch an das Windows 10 Ding hier unten erinnern?
Dieses Windows 10 Menü, was es hier unten gab
Was man dann so ausklappen konnte und so
Moin Patrick, danke schön für den Sub, huge
Dieses alte, alte, die, warte mal
Windows
10 Tray
Tray Taskbar
Ja, ach ne, war das in Windows 10 auch schon so?
Keine Ahnung
Zumindest war das damals so eingestellt
als ich das Notebook neu bekommen habe,
dass dieses Tray-Ding hier
alle Icons angezeigt hat.
Und das war ungelogen.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Die Anzeige
hier
von dem Tray damals
war nicht nur hier,
das ging bis zum Startmenü.
Bis zum Startmenü
gingen die Tray-Icons.
Wegen vorinstalliertem, in Anführungsstrichen,
Security-Zeug.
Die gingen von hier bis hier vorne.
Das war so zugekleistert, was da alles drauf war.
25 Security-Geschiss.
Und das war so krass langsam.
Das haben sie mittlerweile doch ein bisschen besser gemacht.
Das war so heftig langsam.
Ich habe gelesen, die haben bei uns...
Also ich hatte das Problem nicht.
Aber Leute, die vielleicht keinen Admin-Zugang hatten oder sonst was,
keine Ahnung, ob die noch mehr Zeug bekommen haben,
Ich habe gelesen von Leuten, die haben geschrieben bei uns im Intranet,
dass sie 35 Minuten jeden Arbeitstag warten mussten, bis alles ready war auf dem Notebook.
Stellt euch das mal vor. 35 Minuten warten.
WTF? Was das für Geld kostet, Mann.
Also das ist echt heftig.
Also das Problem hatte ich tatsächlich nicht. Ich muss aber dazu sagen, ich verwende mein Windows-Notebook auch nicht. Ich mache es mittlerweile so auf der Arbeit, ich muss das Windows-Notebook verwenden, ja.
Aber Homeoffice ist ganz einfach. Ich mache Zytrix auf, logge mich dort auf meine virtuelle Kiste ein und dort mache ich ein Terminal auf im Fullscreen auf meine Linux-Admin-4M. Fertig.
ich hab dann einfach Terminal im Fullscreen und kann da alles machen was ich will
im Notebook
mach ich es im Prinzip genauso
ich benutze das Notebook
eigentlich nur als
als
Einwahlgerät
für die
VM
und mach da alles auf
also ich verwende von dem Windows darauf nix
das einzige was ich
von Windows verwende sind halt die Sachen die Pflicht sind
ja zum Beispiel Outlook
und sowas kommst du halt nicht drum rum
Wobei Outlook echt ganz gut mittlerweile auch unter Linux funktioniert.
Ich rede von der Web-Version.
Die kann nicht alles, was die Desktop-Version kann,
aber rein für E-Mails gucken, E-Mails antworten und so,
ist dieses Web-Interface von Outlook auch vollkommen fein.
Und deutlich schneller und weniger geruckelt und weniger gezuckelt
wie die Desktop-Version von Outlook.
Weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt.
Outlook WebView oder irgendwie sowas.
Wie hat die Firma das da gelöst mit AD-Anbindung?
Ich war nicht angebunden ans AD.
Ganz einfach.
OWA.
Outlook Web Access.
Genau, das meine ich.
Dieses Ding hier.
Outlook.
OWA.
Ah, genau.
Dieser hässliche Kampel hier.
Das geht eigentlich voll klar.
Das läuft mittlerweile besser als die Desktop-Outlook-Variante.
Ich war gar nicht am AD angemeldet in der alten Firma.
Das war auch sehr nice.
Da konnten die mir nicht irgendeinen Mist auf mein Linux-Notebook pushen.
Ich weiß noch, es gab witzigerweise mal die Initiative beim alten Arbeitgeber,
dass auf allen Linux-Servern und auf Linux-Clients Windows Defender installiert werden muss.
Das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt.
Ihr müsst euch mal vorstellen, es heißt nicht Windows Defender, aber es ist Windows Defender.
Es heißt Microsoft Endpoint Security oder irgendwie sowas.
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal.
Microsoft Endpoint.
Microsoft Defender für Endpunkt unter Linux.
Also ich meine, allein schon den Namen, sowas kann sich nur Microsoft ausdenken
Das klingt schon so geistig irgendwie komplett bescheuert
Microsoft Defender für Endpunkt unter Linux
Genau, das wollten die da einführen
Und wir haben das dann auf einem unserer Notebooks installiert und das hat instant gefreest
Ohne Spaß, instant gefreest
Und danach hat sich das nie mehr einer installiert
und wir mussten das dann auch auf alle Linux-Server installieren
und das hat so viele Probleme gemacht, dieses Ding, ja.
Das hat random irgendwelche Oracle-Datenbank-Files gelockt
und die Datenbank hing, und das Schlimmste an diesem,
das wirklich mit Abstand das Schlimmste an dieser Software ist,
dass Microsoft hier Anwendungsupdates und Virensignaturen-Updates vermischt.
Also du würdest ja erwarten, okay, das Ding aktualisiert sich regelmäßig,
die Virensignaturen und es gibt dann alle paar Patch-Zyklen gibt es halt Software-Updates,
wo du die ja auch mal testen musst.
Aber nein, Microsoft hat hier Push für diese Sache, Software-Updates für diesen Defender
und Virensignaturen und Security-Sachen in einem.
Das heißt, du wachst dann am einen Morgen auf und fragst dich, ey, warum hat denn unser
Fileserver seit heute Nacht auf einmal 50% mehr CPU-Last?
Du kommst dann irgendwann drauf, ah, okay, so nach zwei Tagen oder so kommst du drauf,
Da war okay, Microsoft hat mal wieder irgendein Software-Update für Defender gepusht.
Das war wirklich der absolute Bodensatz an Schrott-Software, Microsoft Defender für Linux.
Das war so ein Shit.
Das Letzte, was ich mitgekriegt habe von der alten Arbeit, kurz bevor ich weg bin, ist,
dass sie gerade wieder dabei sind, das abzuschaffen oder wahrscheinlich mittlerweile wieder abgeschafft haben.
Und jetzt, so 360 Grad Full Circle, auf meiner neuen Arbeit, überlegen sie sich jetzt,
Microsoft Defender für Linux einzuführen.
Und das erste Mal, als ich das gehört habe, bin ich gleich zu meinem Chef und habe gesagt, Chef, das könnt ihr doch nicht machen. Das ist die übelste Kacksoftware. Und dann hat mein Chef gesagt, schreib doch mal an die Verantwortlichen für dieses Demo-Projekt da eine Mail mit deinen Erfahrungen.
Ich habe eine Mail mit meinen Erfahrungen da an die Verantwortlichen geschrieben und die Antwort war sinngemäß, ja hier, danke Max für deine Einschätzung, das deckt sich auch mit unseren Befürchtungen, haben sie geschrieben, das deckt sich auch mit unseren Befürchtungen, allerdings liegt das nicht in unserer Hand, das wurde schon an anderer Stelle entschieden, dass wir das einführen.
geil warum macht man überhaupt ein fucking demo projekt das ist wirklich
hatte so ist das halt so ist so ist das halt mit business enterprise ja da ist
das halt cyberark für zukunft cyberark ist auch so ein ding für sich ja
chat gefasst dass jemand kennt da hatte ich beim alten arbeitgeber auch mal
Spaß damit. CyberArk.
Das ist ein
Tool für
so Versicherungen
und Banken. Damit kannst
du ganz viel machen.
Ihr kennt das.
Chat-Gefrage. Kennt jemand von euch CyberArk?
Also
außer die zwei, die jetzt geschrieben haben im
Chat.
Kennt das jemand? Also das ist eine Software,
mit der kannst du enorm viel machen.
Unter anderem kannst
du damit Remote-Zukämpfe
aufzeichnen also ihr verbindet euch per rdp auf dem server das ding kann aufzeichnen was ihr auf
dem server macht ihr verwendet verbindet euch per ssh auf den server das ding kann quasi eure
tastendrücke aufzeichnen so und dreimal dürft ihr raten wie kannst du die tastendrücke die
beziehungsweise sachen die gemacht werden über eine ssh verbindung wie kannst du die aufzeichnen
wie ist eigentlich so ziemlich der einzige Weg, wie das funktioniert?
High IQ Chat G.
Root Kid.
Ja, ne.
Ne, du brauchst den SSH Man in the Middle Proxy.
Anders funktioniert das nicht.
Und genau das bietet CyberArk unter anderem.
Du verbindest dich dann nicht direkt auf den Server.
du verbindest dich per SSH
auf CyberArk
und sagst CyberArk, auf was du weiter
geproxied werden musst.
Oder weiter geproxied werden willst.
Und dann verbindet CyberArk sich zu dem Zielserver
und schleift die Verbindung
dann so durch. Und deswegen kann CyberArk
deine komplette SSH-Session mitlocken.
Und das ist so
ultra krasser Abfuck.
Weil du kannst
die Hälfte der Sachen, die SSH bietet
nicht richtig benutzen.
Willst du dir einen Port weiterleiten, um was auszuprobieren?
Vergiss es.
Kannst du knicken.
Was ich mittlerweile mache, ich habe das ein bisschen outplayed, dieses System.
Bei uns ist es so, wenn du dich über CyberArk verbindest, musst du immer ganz viele Sachen eingeben.
Doch, doch, doch, SCP geht.
Aber jetzt pass mal auf, wie SCP geht.
SCP geht nur mit Trick 17.
Also direkt SCP geht schon mal nicht.
Du musst SCP auch proxien.
aber SCP hat ja Probleme mit interaktiven Abfragen, die da so kommen,
weil SCP macht ja halt File Transfer und kein Input-Output normalerweise.
So, also das ist, wenn du dich per CyberArk einloggst,
sagst du dann hier SSH, ähm, äh, hier und dann hier, äh, CyberArk Proxy.
So, ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, wie das funktioniert.
Du musst das irgendwie so zweigeteilt angeben.
Da, wo du eigentlich hin willst und dann der eigentliche SSH-Host, wo du dich hin verbinden willst.
Ich glaube, du musst das hier als Username übergeben.
So musst du das, glaube ich, schreiben.
Guck, root at den Server, wo du hin willst, at diesem CyberArk-Proxy.
Irgendwie so musst du das schreiben im Endeffekt, dass das funktioniert.
Ganz wir.
und wenn du das dann ausführst, das geht jetzt natürlich bei mir nicht, weil es diese IP nicht gibt,
dann kommen bei uns jede Menge Fragen.
Da kommt dann so wie, warum greifst du auf das System zu?
Und dann musst du dann angeben, Ticket 123456.
Wie ist dein Passwort? 123456.
Gebe zwei Faktortoken vom Handy ein. 123456.
So, das musst du dann alles eingeben und das kann SCP nicht.
Also das injectet das ja quasi on the fly, dieser Cyberark-Proxy injectet das ja quasi on the fly in eine SSH-Verbildung, damit kommt SCP nicht klar.
So und jetzt Trick 17 für alle Cyberark-Geplagten.
Ihr müsst SSH, ich hab vergessen wie es heißt, SSH, dieses SSH-Session-Management müsst ihr verwenden.
ssh session
ähm
wie hieß das nochmal
cache connection
irgendwie so wie ging das nochmal
oh fuck ich hab vergessen wie es heißt
master
irgendwie ssh master control
so hieß das doch irgendwo
Genau, genau, genau. SSH-Control-Master müsst ihr in eure SSH-Config reinschreiben. Ja, sowas hier. Sowas hier müsst ihr in eure SSH-Config reinschreiben.
So und was dann passiert ist, wenn ihr einmal diese SSH-Verbindung aufmacht und einmal diesen ganzen Mist von Passwort, Zwei-Faktor-Organifizierung, Ticketnummer eingegeben habt, dann merkt sich euer SSH diese Verbindung für 10 Minuten und ihr könnt die nächsten 10 Minuten euch wieder auf den Host verbinden, ohne dass ihr dieses ganze Gedulds angeben müsst, weil SSH die Verbindung quasi cached.
letztendlich macht es hat er nur noch eine master verbindung auf und jede weitere ssh bindung auf
ssh verbindung auf diesen endpoint nutzt die schon bestehende ssh verbindung diese master
verbindung die schon gibt damit könnt ihr selber ein bisschen aus tricksen und dieses man braucht
jedes mal geduld eingeben könnt ihr umgehen und damit funktioniert dann auch scp damit funktioniert
dann auch SCP. Ja, also
wer CyberArk geplagt ist, macht das
in eurer SSH-Config und stellt
es auf die maximale Zeit, die euer CyberArk
erlaubt, äh,
wie die Verbindung offen ist.
Den nur Dankeschön für den Sub. Huge
Subscription.
Also so kann man das
ein bisschen austricksen. Genau.
Und das ist, das ist wirklich super krasse
Abfuck-Software, ne?
Ja, aber ich war ja vor, ich war ja
vorher noch, noch am erzählen. Wisst ihr,
Wisst ihr, woran man erkennt, dass die Softwareverwaltung für Windows im Kern 30 Jahre alt ist bei uns auf der Arbeit?
Da werden so Sachen wie UltraEdit vorinstalliert.
Seriously, UltraEdit. Kennt das überhaupt noch jemand?
Fucking UltraEdit. Das hat man 1996 verwendet, um Text zu editieren unter Windows.
Weil Notepad damals auch schon kacke war.
Ultra, Ultra Edit.
Also, keine Ahnung, warum man das heutzutage noch benutzt.
Aber solche Sachen sind da teilweise vorinstalliert.
WTF?
Ultra Edit.
Kann ich nicht verstehen.
So Uralt-Zeug wird da installiert.
Ich habe eh Mitleid für Leute, die hauptsächlich dann ihre Arbeit unter Windows erledigen müssen.
Ich habe ja das Glück, ich kann Windows im Endeffekt als, ich sag mal, als X-Server verwenden.
Für eine Linux-Terminal. Und damit ist gut.
Also ich benutze kein WSL.
Ich habe eine Linux-Admin-Kiste, wo ich Hutrechte drauf habe und alles machen kann.
16 Kerne, 32 GigaRAM,
also es hat ordentlich Power, das Ding.
Kostet wahrscheinlich auch 500 Euro im Monat, was auch immer,
aber die Firma bezahlt es ja.
Und die wollen das ja auch so.
Und dann mache ich nur noch ein Terminal
da drauf auf, ein großes
Fullscreen-Terminator-Terminal
und dann ist gut, fertig.
Gibt es eigentlich
Terminator für Windows?
Ne.
It is available on Windows.
Seriously, wirklich?
Äh, ne, das ist was ganz anderes.
Das ist...
Das ist was anderes.
Das ist nicht das, was ich meine.
Oder doch?
Doch, das könnte es sein.
Das gibt es für Windows Native, okay.
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Genau, aber damit, wie gesagt,
damit geht auch SCP.
Chat, jetzt wo ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind, muss ich das gerade auch mal erzählen.
Ich habe es am Anfang des Streams schon erzählt.
Heute war mega brutal, was mein Garmin-Trainingsplan vorgeschlagen hat.
10 Minuten einlaufen, 19 Minuten schnell rennen, 5 Minuten langsam gehen, 19 Minuten schnell rennen.
Und dann habe ich mich so 13, 14 Minuten noch ausgelaufen.
Das war echt brutal. Fast 11 Kilometer gerannt.
und ich bin echt, also ich bin
richtig fertig gewesen danach.
In welcher Pulszone
ist schnell Rennen? Moment, kann ich dir sagen,
ich hatte, äh,
Moment, Moment, Moment, äh, hä?
Power, Elevation,
hier, Heart Rate.
Also, ich hatte so
160,
Puls,
also ungefähr
160 so in dem Drehpuls
bei
ja ich würde sagen im Durchschnitt so
160 Puls bei diesen 2x19 Minuten
schnell und das ist bei mir
muss ich mal kurz gucken, ob man das hier
überhaupt irgendwo sieht
Heart Rate Zones, Moment
das muss ich mal gucken, sowas gibt es hier bestimmt
Performance Stats
äh
L-Stats
ich habe absolut
Keine Ahnung, wo man Heartrate-Zones sieht.
Training und Plan vielleicht?
Keine Ahnung.
Also die Garmin... Ah, hier Heartrate.
Hier Heartrate. Ne.
Also die Garmin-App ist mittlerweile so kompliziert,
die bräuchte eine Suchfunktion.
Aber man sieht das, glaube ich, auch.
Moment mal, ich guck mal hier.
Da stehen ja diese Zonen und so.
Bei Stats steht das irgendwo.
Da gibt es doch immer so eine Übersicht, in welchen Zonen man hauptsächlich...
Ah, hier. Okay, okay.
Ach nee, Time in Power Zones. Time in Heart Rate Zones.
Also, Zone 4. Ich bin...
Ich bin 4 Minuten in Zone 2 gerannt.
11 Minuten in Zone 3.
Und 49 Minuten in Zone 4.
In Zone 5 gar nicht.
So, Zone 4 ist bei mir 147 bis 166.
Puls.
Steht daneben.
Also das war echt anstrengend.
Also zweimal 19 Minuten schnell, wirklich, das ist schon nicht ohne.
Das kannst du aber besser systemplatt machen. Du kannst einfach deine Festplatte DDen. Du DDest einfach die ersten 4K von deiner SSD und dann sieht das so aus, als ist die Festplatte nackig.
Einfach dd
dd
bs gleich 4k
count gleich 1
if gleich
def 0, of def
ja nvme irgendwas
Aber das war heute
wirklich krass anstrengend, also da war ich
wirklich richtig fertig danach
So
Dann loggen wir uns, wir machen jetzt erstmal
einen Reboot würde ich sagen
Reboot.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
ich bin am durchdrehen, wenn ich strebe.
Chat, ist jetzt zwar schon eine Woche her,
hat einer von euch die letzte Etappe,
weil während das hier gerade rebootet,
die letzte Etappe von Natur der Frost geguckt?
Das war eines der geilsten
Rennen, die ich je gesehen habe.
Also,
So, das...
Die letzten 20 Kilometer oder so.
Kann man sich Aliase mit Reknexe machen?
Nee, das habe ich viel, viel...
Low IQ mäßig gelöst.
Das kann ich dir...
Das kann ich dir zeigen, wie ich das gelöst habe.
Dass ich beliebig viele R's für Reboot eingeben kann.
Die letzten 20 Kilometer der letzten Tour de France Etappe waren echt richtig nice.
Und ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass er noch gewinnt.
Das war ja wirklich, das war ja...
Zentimeter, ey.
Ein CMD-Not-Found-Händler.
Nee, auch nicht. Auch nicht. Auch nicht.
So, jetzt haben wir hier den Kran.
Firefox starten.
Zack.
Jetzt müssen wir Firefox nochmal
Private Window starten.
Links starten.
Ja, ich hab das auch 3-Head gemacht.
Low IQ.
Pass mal auf.
Also, guck mal.
So funktioniert das, dass ich mehrfach Reboot, so viele Rs eingeben kann, wie ich will.
Beziehungsweise bis zu 200 Rs eingeben kann, dass es als Reboot funktioniert.
Ich verstehe leider nicht mal genau, was ich da gebaut habe.
Also, lass mal überlegen.
Eine Schleife, 1 bis 200.
Und dann lege ich einen Alias an.
Was?
Echo MyStringPrintF.
Okay, hier steht dann 1S, 2S, 3S, 4S drin.
Je nachdem, wie viele Schleifendurchläufe wir gerade haben.
Und dann...
...replace ich mein String...
...durch einen...
Ich check das nicht mal, was ich da gemacht habe.
Okay, pass mal auf.
Explain.
Geh weg.
Welches Terminal ich verwende?
West Term. Beste.
Kann ich gleich was zu sagen, warum das das Beste ist?
Also, this Bash Snippet
is an obfuscated...
Hey! Wie?
Da ist nichts obfuscated. Das ist komplett obvious.
Nur weil ich das jetzt nicht mehr weiß,
muss es auch nicht gleich obfuscated sein.
Create 200
Aliases for the reboot command.
Ja, so schlau war ich auch schon.
Okay, loop. Runs the loop.
Building the alias name.
Okay, I gleich 5, dann kommt dann
Ach, das macht Spaces
Jetzt verstehe ich das
Das macht so viele Spaces
Wie es Schleifendurchläufe gibt
Und dann replace ich die Spaces
Mit einem R
Das heißt, da kommt dann bei 5 Spaces
Werden die 5 Spaces durch 5 Rs replaced
Und dementsprechend habe ich 1 bis 200 Mal die Möglichkeit
Reboot zu schreiben.
Jetzt verstehe ich es wieder.
Okay.
Nice.
Hat ChatGPT auch einen besseren Weg,
das zu machen?
A simpler equivalent.
Finde ich das jetzt so viel simpler?
Nee, finde ich nicht.
Mostly as a joke.
Nee, nee, ich benutze das ernsthaft.
So, dann loggen wir uns mal.
Ach nee, ich wollte ja vorhin noch was zum Terminal sagen.
Also ich benutze Westterm.
GitHub, Wetsterm.
Gibt es eigentlich mittlerweile ein neues Release.
Die planen da ja schon ewig dran rum.
Ich habe irgendein Daily-Build.
Nee, das letzte Release ist zwei Jahre, two years ago.
aber ich benutze irgendeinen Daily Build.
Und da tut sich auch viel.
Westterm. Warum ich Westterm benutze, hat mehrere Gründe.
Das erste ist, was ich sehr nice finde,
es hat Image Support,
was nicht viele Terminals haben.
Und Image Support im Terminal, sogar GIF Support im Terminal,
ist sehr
POG.
Western läuft wohl auch unter Windows.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also, Image Support im Terminal finde ich
sehr nice und finde ich auch
wichtig und richtig,
dass es das gibt.
Das nächste ist,
was benutzt du oft?
Die Multiplex-Funktion.
Du meinst, dass ich in mehreren
Splits
mit einem Tastendruck das gleiche schreibe,
oder was meinst du?
Dass ich quasi jetzt
einmal D drücke und es würde es bei beiden
reinschreiben, benutze ich so gut wie gar nicht.
Ab und zu.
Aber so gut wie gar nicht.
Ich wusste, ganz ehrlich, wenn ich das mache,
ach, zu splitten, ja, das
benutze ich laufend.
Das benutze ich laufend.
So, das nächste ist, das wollte ich eigentlich auch gerade sagen,
das nächste ist, du brauchst kein Temux mehr,
um Splits, vertikale und horizontale Splits zu machen.
Das kann alles Westterm und kann dann auch schön resizen.
Und der Vorteil im Vergleich zu Temux ist,
dass Terminal weiß, dass das hier ein Split ist.
Guck, wenn ich hier kopiere,
da kopiert er nicht das Komplette,
sondern wirklich nur das, was ich markiere.
Wenn man da Temux startet, sieht das ja anders aus.
Wenn ich in Temux das Gleiche mache,
im Endeffekt, und jetzt hier was schreibe und das markieren will,
Temux hat ja keine Ahnung von Terminal-Grenzen.
Ja?
Wenn du bei Temux, beziehungsweise Terminal,
keine Ahnung von Temux grenzen. Also wenn du bei
Temux kopierst, siehst du hier, ne?
Also wenn du mit Maus das so im Terminal
kopieren willst, checkt er das nicht.
Deswegen finde ich das halt sehr nice bei
Westterm, dass du das direkt machen kannst.
Was für mich ein weiterer Vorteil
ist, ich kann lokal bei
mir Splits, horizontale
Splits und Tabs und sowas
benutzen und Temux auf
dem Server. Früher musste ich immer
Ja, ich weiß, dass man
T-Mux, aber das finde ich
hakelig. Das hier ist viel, viel angenehmer.
Zumal Mausrad und so
alles wunderbar funktioniert. Das ist schon besser
als in T-Mux.
Es schützt dann auch ein bisschen vor T-Mux in T-Mux,
weil, wenn man,
früher hatte ich das so, T-Mux offen,
dann habe ich SSH gemacht,
hier Local Host, keine Ahnung, habe ich nicht
laufen und dann habe ich in T-Mux quasi
im T-Mux gestartet.
Das sah dann im Endeffekt bei mir so aus.
Ist? Nein, ernst. So muss ich es machen.
Da hatte ich dann T-Mux in T-Mux.
Hier per SSH auf dem Server und meins lokal.
Da musstest du dann immer doppelt Escape drücken, wenn du was machen willst.
Das war richtig eklig.
So, deswegen bevorzuge ich das eindeutig hier mit Westterm Splits.
Und das Schöne daran ist natürlich, man kann nicht nur splitten, man kann auch Tabs aufmachen.
Also du kannst hier dein Kram laufen lassen zum Beispiel.
hier askiquarium und
GIFs
und hier
irgendwas gedöhnts und dann kannst du
entweder machst du ein weiteres Tab auf oder
sowas, kannst du hier Resizen oder
machst ein neues Tab auf
und kannst dann hier parallel was tippen.
Das ist enorm praktisch und dann kannst du hier
das Tab zurückswitchen und hast wieder alles noch da.
Das ist wie in Temux
nur besser, weil es kein Temux
in Temux gibt, wenn du es per SSH verwendest.
Also das ist eines der
besten features in thema in dem es auch in western ja du kannst auch einfach was maximieren ja wenn
du sagst ey guck mal hier läuft das aquarium ich will den jetzt im fullscreen anzeigen kannst du
einfach auch sagen ich will dieses dieses panel hier will ich maximieren und dann hast du dieses
panel kurzzeitig im fullscreen oder kannst es wieder klein machen also das ist quasi wie
teiling window manager ohne teiling window manager und viel viel besser ja also dass das ist wirklich
top. Das ist eines der Features schlechthin,
warum ich Temux nice finde. Wie gesagt, neben
Image Support. Und
was ich auch bei Westerm
mega pock finde, ist
ich kann es euch mal
kurz zeigen.
Wobei, ich habe da ein Alias für. Ich brauche euch das gar nicht zu sagen.
Die Westerm-Config ist
auch geil. Die Westerm-Config
ist nämlich keine reine Config,
sondern ist ein
Lua-Skript.
Das heißt, die gesamte
Config kannst du Lua-Konstrukte
verwenden wie vorschleifen und sowas.
Und das ist schon nice. Das heißt,
wenn das Terminal irgendwelche Sachen
nicht so macht, wie du gerne
hättest,
kann das auch Tabs,
ja, hab ich doch schon gezeigt hier unten, guck.
Guck unten auf dem Bildschirm.
Da hab ich verschiedene Tabs jetzt, die ich grad durchswitche.
Ja, wenn das Terminal
was nicht so macht, wie du gerne hättest,
ich hab kein i3 mehr, das ist KDE.
Das ist KDE.
Ich weiß, ich benutze das wie E3, aber das ist KDE
So, das heißt, wenn das Terminal
Irgendwas macht, was dir nicht so
Gefällt, kannst du das skripten
In der Config
Und das ist halt super nice
Zum Beispiel, was ich da gescriptort habe, was ihr hier oben seht
Ist, guck mal, wenn ich hier
Was markieren will in der Shell
und in den Zwischenablager kopieren will, kann ich jetzt das Anklicken, rechte Maustaste drücken
und das nächste Mal rechte Maustaste drücken, pastet.
Und das funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Ihr seht es ja hier oben, mittlere Maustaste, Tastetaste, ihr seht es ja hier.
Der guckt, ist was selected.
Wenn was selected ist, also wenn Text selected ist, dann Copy to Clipboard.
Das heißt, wenn Text selected ist und ich drücke die rechte Maustaste, dann wird dieser Text ins Clipboard kopiert und die Selection gecleart.
Also ich drücke jetzt rechte Maustaste, wird ins Clipboard kopiert und die Selection gecleart.
Und else, wenn nichts selected ist, dann macht die rechte Maustaste Paste Primary Selection.
Also ich kann mit der rechten Maustaste, kann ich jetzt kopien und pasten.
das macht das Terminal standardmäßig so nicht,
aber dadurch, dass das eben
Lua-Config ist, in der Config,
kann man sich sowas selbst basteln, und das ist schon mega nice.
Dazu kommt, dass du hier alles mögliche noch
umbelegen kannst, wobei, das kannst du bei den meisten,
kannst du bei den meisten Terminals,
sagen kannst, was denn jetzt hier,
welche Shortcuts und so, was
das macht, das ist schon
okay, das geht bei vielen anderen Sachen auch.
Du kannst das Fenster ganz gut
customizen, ja, also ich hab links
und rechts ein kleines padding dass das nicht so am rand klebt oben und unten habe ich kein padding
ich habe eine opacity ihr seht im hintergrund wenn ihr ganz genau guckt seht ihr im hintergrund ein
bisschen guck hier ein bisschen den pepo durch scheinen das ist 99 prozent soll es aber ein
prozent ein prozent scheint der hintergrund durch keine windows decorations die tab bar
Da ist unten...
Oh, kannst du hier alles mögliche...
Kannst du da alles mögliche einstellen.
Kannst auch den Font einstellen.
Ich will Hack als Font benutzen.
Aber ich will auch...
Oh, das habe ich jetzt hier gar nicht mehr.
Hat KDE
einen Emoji Selector?
Excellent.
Ja. So.
Und das benutzt aber auch
Tvimoji.
Da sind aber gar keine Tvimojis.
Sind das Tvimojis?
Moment, ich habe überhaupt kein Timochi-Font installiert hier.
Wann das denn?
Das, Leute.
Was ist da los?
Ich habe kein Timochi-Font installiert.
Das ist der Default-KDE mitgelieferte Emoji-Font.
Gut, kann ich auch mitleben.
Aber man kann auch sagen, was der benutzen soll.
Und man kann natürlich Farb-Color-Schemes hier festlegen, wie das aussehen soll.
genau so sieht es aus also deswegen ist western enorm ja es gibt konflikt falls
hier es gibt wo blogs github config dort falls die habe ich schon eine weile nicht
mehr aktualisiert aber da hat sich kaum was getan also hast du zum beispiel bei
meine Westterm-Config, die ist
immer noch gültig
für die aktuelle Stable-Version
von Westterm.
Guck, du siehst, viel Unterschied ist da nicht.
Also kann man sich
daran orientieren.
Vieles davon
braucht man allerdings nicht mehr mit dem Setup.
Ja, also zum Beispiel
die, wobei, was heißt vieles, so viel
ist es nicht. Ja, zum Beispiel die Config
für
Rofi braucht man nicht mehr, benutze ich nicht mehr. Ich benutze
jetzt. Und die E3-Config und P-Com
und so, das brauchen wir nicht mehr. Das ist ein KDE auf
Wayland mittlerweile. Bumblebee-Status
braucht man auch nicht mehr.
Weil ich, wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt KDE,
Wayland und halt das
eingebaute Zeug in KDE.
So sieht's aus. Excellent!
Ich muss mir was zu trinken holen.
Max, du bist
doch C++-Fan. Schau dir das hier mal an.
Moment.
Ich trau mich jetzt einfach mal, das aufzumachen, okay?
Oh, der ist aber auch dick geworden.
Von dem habe ich schon öfters Konferenztalks geguckt.
Das wird nie sich durchsetzen, Carbon.
Das wird komplett stiefmütterlich auch behandelt von Google.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir da jemals irgendwas sehen werden in der Richtung.
Wie viel FPS habe ich bei Westterm eingetragen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Habe ich da überhaupt FPS?
Ne, ich habe die Default-FPS bei Westterm.
Wo wir gerade bei C++ sind.
Ich habe letztens bei Hacker News wieder was gelesen über C++.
Aber davon fange ich jetzt nicht an, weil da fangen wir mit...
Machen wir heute keine Set Servers mehr, wenn ich jetzt von C++ anfange.
Ich muss mich da bremsen lassen.
Ihr wisst, ich flame immer ganz gerne über C++.
So Leute, ich hole mir mal kurz was zu trinken.
Ich bin gleich wieder am Start und dann legen wir los.
So, da bin ich wieder.
Gut.
Dann wollen wir mal, hä?
Also, setservers.com.
Chat, ihr müsst mir versprechen, jetzt wegzugucken.
Aber ich weiß, ich kann euch ja trauen.
Deswegen muss ich den Bildschirm sicherlich nicht schwarz machen.
Ich muss mich nämlich einloggen.
Und da sieht man, wenn ich Pech habe,
kurz mein Passwort.
Und das will ich nicht.
Schon drin.
Fuck.
Wer hat gehackermanned schon wieder?
Ich muss nur gucken, dass ich mich jetzt nicht vertippe
bei meinem Passwort.
Schon habe ich mich vertippt.
So, ich hoffe, jetzt passt das.
Okay, gut.
Wir sind wieder am Start.
Ich mache Bildschirm an.
Zack.
Exzellente.
Kannst du kurz
jetzt noch was erklären? Ja, klar.
Mache ich immer, wenn wir
Neuanfang. Also Beispiel.
Guck mal. Du kriegst bei Set Servers
Achso, warte mal. Moment, Moment. Es gab eben
Es gab doch eben noch eine Frage
ob sich Pro
Lohnt sich der Pro oder der Pro Plus Plan
für Set Servers?
Ich hab tatsächlich mir einen
Pro Plan
geholt
Ich hab mir einen Pro Plus Plan geholt
Das liegt aber daran
weil ich SSH-Login für den Stream haben will und ich alle Pro-Szenarios machen möchte.
Also ich finde, der Preis ist für, wenn du das einfach am Stück mal durcharbeiten willst,
für einen Monat oder zwei, ist der vollkommen okay.
Du musst es ja nicht gleich für ein Jahr abschließen oder so.
Vielleicht hast du aber auch die Chance, wenn du sagst, ich will mich da weiterbilden, sonst was,
vielleicht kannst du es auch über deine Firma kaufen.
Kommt immer ein bisschen drauf an, wie empfänglich die für sowas sind
Aber für ein paar Monate der Pro-Plan
Finde ich vollkommen fein für das, was man dann kriegt
Gut, also jetzt kann ich das Ganze nochmal erklären
Bei Set-Servers
Könnt ihr euch übrigens einen Account machen
Und ihr könnt alle Szenarios, wo hier nicht Pro dran steht
Könnt ihr kostenlos machen
Oh, es gibt wieder ein paar neue
Also das ist eine Seite
Mit
71.
Alter, fuck haben die mittlerweile viel.
19 plus 71 plus 30.
Die haben mittlerweile 120 Szenarien.
Also du hast hier 120 Szenarien.
Jedes Szenario, wir machen das mal, das eine wieder auf.
Jedes Szenario ist ein kaputter Linux-Server.
Oder, sagen wir mal.
muss nicht unbedingt ein kaputter Linux-Server sein.
Aber jedes Szenario kriegst du eine Problembeschreibung
und du musst dafür sorgen, dass das Problem behoben wird
und das Server danach wieder funktioniert.
Guck wie beispielsweise, das ist das erste Szenario unter Easy.
Also das ist auch wirklich easy.
Also geht es im Prinzip darum, es gibt ein Log-File,
was die Festplatte vollschreibt und du bist der Admin von diesem Server
und du sollst das Programm, was die Logfiles schreibt, beenden.
Zack. So.
Dann kannst du das starten.
Dann, das Ding professioniert dir einen echten AWS Linux Server unter der Haube.
Das heißt, das ist keine Emulator-Umgebung oder sowas.
Du hast wirklich einen richtig echten Linux Server.
Einen Linux VM, auf der du üben kannst.
Also auch keine irgendwelche Sonderheiten, die der Emulator nicht richtig macht.
Nein, das ist ein echt echter Linux-Server.
Unter der Haube funktioniert das halt so.
Der professioniert sich da bei AWS.
Eine VM lässt per Ansible-Skripts laufen.
Und dann hast du halt eben den Server, wie das Szenario das beschreibt.
Hast du eigentlich dein Postgres-Problem von letzter Woche gelöst?
Nee, noch nicht.
Aber eure Vorschläge, die ihr gemacht habt zum Thema...
selbst ein Admin darf auf einem Kubernetes Cluster nicht alles machen.
Die wurden sehr wohlwollend aufgenommen.
So mit Checksum überprüfen.
Was hatten wir, was hattet ihr vorgeschlagen?
Checksum überprüfen von Images
und nach einmal falsch,
nach einer Message, die nicht stimmt,
automatisch die Anwendung restarten.
Ja, das war eine gute Idee.
So, wir verbinden uns jetzt mal per SSH dahin.
Ja, zack, SSH, dahin.
Yes.
So, jetzt sind wir auf dem Server drauf.
Also, und die sagen in diesem Szenario, hier gibt es eine Datei, war Log, Bad Log.
Und nachdem wir alle krasse Linux-Experts sind, wissen wir, dass wir so nachgucken können,
welcher Prozess in diese Datei schreibt.
Und dann sagt ihr, okay, dieser Prozess ist es, PID 103, also kill.
Zack.
Und jetzt schreibt nix mehr in die Logdatei rein.
Und jetzt geht ihr hier hin und sagt, check my solution.
Und dann guckt der nach, ob das stimmt, was ihr gemacht habt.
Und jawohl, hat funktioniert.
Und falls es nicht funktioniert, ihr könnt euch auch Hilfe anzeigen lassen.
Für das jeweilige Problem.
Wenn ihr nicht weiterkommt.
Das war jetzt aber wie gesagt, das war jetzt ein einfaches Beispiel.
Es war easy Aufgabe 1.
Das war auch wirklich easy.
Und davon gibt es jetzt halt 120 Szenarien mittlerweile.
So, hast du es verstanden, Leonidas?
Leonidas, wie die Amis dazu sagen.
Okay, so. Also, wir haben alles mit dem Häkchen schon gemacht. Das hier ist irgendwas, wo es nichts zu machen gibt.
Also, wir haben alle Easy-Szenarien bis auf eines durch. Wir haben, würde ich mal sagen, knapp die Hälfte der Medium-Szenarien durch.
und wir haben so einen Drittel vielleicht der schweren Szenarien durch.
Da wollen wir doch mal.
Wir fangen mal mit was Mittlerem an.
Chat, ihr könnt euch was aussuchen.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Was sagen wir denn hier?
Ihr könnt euch was aussuchen zwischen 34 und...
Und machen wir so.
Zwischen 34 und 44.
Könnt ihr euch ein Szenario aussuchen.
Die Beschreibung gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Das müsst ihr rein anhand vom Titel machen.
34?
Okay.
Control one container from another.
Okay, dann machen wir 34.
Oder wir gucken uns mal an, was wir über 34 überhaupt machen müssen.
Also Description.
Machen wir. Gut, machen wir 34.
Also es gibt einen Container named Docker Access.
Okay.
Und einen weiteren Container Engine X.
Aber der ist stoppt.
So, unser Goal ist es,
unser goal ist das wird sagen dass unser key zum success also das ziel ist es den
engine x container zu starten von dem docker access container
you must not start the engine x container from the host system
or any other container da ist noch docker access ok ok da kann man jetzt gleich mal
Da können wir jetzt gleich mal probieren, ob man da tricksen kann.
Ich hätte gleich schon auf professionieren drücken sollen, dass es jetzt nicht erst noch sich hier hochfahren muss.
Achtung Leute, Flashbang
Wir machen mal den offiziellen
Dark Mode, das kann man ein bisschen besser erkennen
Der Spinner hätte noch
angepasst werden können für den Dark Mode
Das Spinner-Design ist nicht so schön im Dark-Mode, weil es der gleiche Spinner ist wie im Light-Mode.
Aber ich darf da gar nicht meckern, meine Webseiten und CSS-Skills würden doch deutlich schlechter aussehen.
Was sind denn Labs eigentlich?
Achso, das ist jetzt im Prinzip nochmal...
Darf man Docker Socket in Docker Access bauen?
Wir müssen mal gucken, was hier angesagt ist.
Also, verbinden wir uns mal per SSH da drauf.
SSH, zack.
Yes.
also docker ps gucken wir mal locker ps wir sind nicht mal kuba netz ps
ich bin verwirrt leute wenn man zu viel kuba niederstellt macht vergisst man die docker befehle
Okay, guck, hier gibt es
Docker Access
Der ist exited
Und es gibt
Nginx
Jetzt warte mal, kann man das ganze cheesen
Indem ich einfach sage, Docker Start Nginx
Moment
Das wäre jetzt aber
Beschiss, oder?
No, okay
Okay
You must not start the NGX-Container
from the host system
Okay, okay, okay
Okay, chat, chat
nachdem ich jetzt gleich von Anfang an was gemacht
habe, was ich nicht machen darf,
würde ich, okay,
komm, wir stoppen den einfach. Docker stopp
Nginx. Okay?
So, jetzt ist er weg.
Passt schon. Also,
was ist denn das Ziel?
Executing Docker PS
inside the Docker Access Container?
Ja, succeeds.
Das ist der Test?
Okay.
Also, Docker.
Dart. Probieren wir das mal.
Docker Access.
Bam.
Läuft. Exec.
PS. Cannot connect.
Ach gut, das muss da reingemountet werden anscheinend.
Docker Access.
Kann man sowas hier machen? Bash?
Bin Bash?
Wie war das?
It, gell?
Doch, muss man so machen? War das so?
Kann man das immer nicht merken, ja.
No such file or directory.
Okay.
BNSH ist da.
Docker PS.
Okay.
Das ist einfach nicht da reingemontet.
Sieht zumindest so aus, als ist es nicht da reingemontet.
Wir können da nochmal gucken hier.
Vielleicht stimmen auch die Rechte nicht.
Warlock.
Nee, gibt's nicht. Docker Access.
Ja gut, dann müssen wir das...
Docker Stopp.
Stoppen.
Was ich jetzt nicht aus dem Kopf weiß,
ist, wie man ein bestehendes,
einen bestehenden Docker-Container
editiert.
Gibt es sowas wie
Docker Edit? Bei Kubernetes
gibt es das. Aber bei
Docker anscheinend nicht.
How to edit
Docker-Container.
Keine Ahnung.
Edit Container Details.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Ich mein...
Geht das überhaupt?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich würde normalerweise auch den Container löschen und würde es wieder starten.
Das machen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Wie macht man das bei Docker?
Anzeigen lassen?
Ja, bei Kubernetes ist es einfacher.
Da sagst du, kubectl edit, bla bla bla,
deployment, noch was. Aber wie macht man das bei Docker?
Kann ich mal... Info.
Docker Info, hä?
Ne.
War sowas?
Docker Access oder sowas?
Inspect.
Ah.
Aha.
Da haben wir die ganzen Kempel.
Okay.
Mountet der irgendwas hier drinnen?
Sieht man das?
Arx.
Path.
SH.
Image.
es sieht jetzt nicht so aus als wird da irgendwas irgendwas rein gemontet oder
oder?
Kann man Docker edit mount?
Gibt es sowas?
Auf einem existenten Container, ja.
No, there is no way.
Okay.
Ja, so schlau bin ich auch.
Wie gesagt, ich bin normalerweise auch für Entfernen.
Ja, vom Container.
Aber das ist ja anscheinend nicht gewollt.
Atma.
Mounted der wo?
Mounted der irgendwie was anderes?
Mounts.
Nee, da mountet gar nichts.
Nee, nee, es gibt nichts.
Ich hab schon extra geguckt.
Ich mein, was wir machen können ist,
den hier
zu löschen und dann einfach dieses
Image hier
wieder
Docker Images
minus A, Docker Access
Ja, das können wir machen.
Da sagen wir einfach mal Docker, vielleicht mache ich es jetzt auch kaputt.
Ja, Docker RM
Docker Access
Docker
Run
Wie war das jetzt? Minus it oder so?
Wenn ich minus m
mache, ist es danach wieder weg.
So, und dann sage ich
minus v
war
Wie macht man das jetzt?
Ja, genau.
War?
Lip?
Docker?
Wo ist der Docker-Socket?
War?
Lip?
Docker?
Wo liegt das Ding?
Info?
War Run, hä?
War Run
Docker Socket.
Docker.sock
Das wollen wir haben.
Okay, also dann wollen wir mal hier das rein mounten.
Dahin.
Äh, ja.
Bin.
SH.
Hä?
Ach, fuck.
Wie ging...
Docker-Commands, Alter.
Äh, it.
Docker-Access, ne?
Hä?
Das ging doch so.
Muss das weg?
So, Image brauchen wir ja noch.
Genau, Image.
Image.
Docker Access.
Macht da irgendwas verkehrt?
Ich hab das Image nicht gelöscht.
Ich hab den Container gelöscht.
Äh
Was mache ich denn verkehrt
Das ist der Name und das ist das Image
Oder warte mal
Ah ja
Ähm
Wie war das minus minus name oder so
Ah ja, genau, so will ich das haben
So, und jetzt machen wir hier diesen Krempel davor noch
Dass das gemountet wird
Okay, jetzt hat er wieder irgendwas verkehrt gemacht
Was hat er denn für Schmerzen wieder?
A-V fehlt
das muss davor oder
also muss ich quasi hier sagen locker access ja sehr schön okay jetzt haben wir hier war
run docker socket docker ps funzt sehr gut und jetzt kann ich sagen docker start engine x
ok läuft
execute in docker ps inside docker container succeeds jawoll haben wir
Gut. Ja dann.
Check my solution. Bam.
Eats, Leute. Eats.
Endlich ein deutscher Linux-Stream.
Ja, wir machen das öfters.
Easy.
Wenn man diese ganze Docker-Syntax
zu einem Kopf hat, dann ist das wahrscheinlich noch deutlich einfacher.
Excellent
Geschafft, Leute
Next
So
Okay
Ihr könnt euch das nächste Szenario aussuchen
35 bis 45
Clickhouse
Ist Clickhouse nicht
Irgend so ne
Analytics-Metrik-Gedöns-Datenbank
44 und 39
Okay, machen wir die in der Reihenfolge
44 und
Och nein
Nein, Zertifikatszeug, please.
Ihr wollt mich quälen mit dem Scheiß, oder?
Zertifikatskrempel ist immer absoluter Painschamp.
Okay, wir machen das.
Wir machen das trotzdem in der Reihenfolge.
Kriege ich wieder Anfälle bei Zertifikatskram.
Also, machen wir mal Run und dann lesen wir uns mal durch, was wir eigentlich machen müssen.
Ah, es gibt, wir haben eine Clickhouse-Installation.
Chat, ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe in meinem Leben noch nicht Clickhouse verwendet.
Ich weiß, dass das irgendeine Analytics-Geschichte ist oder sowas.
Aber noch nie benutzt.
Wir haben für Clickhouse Installation G running.
Oh, ein Kubernetes-Cluster.
And a set of requests.
That you must populate into a HTTP-Request-Table in the monitoring database.
Moment, what?
Was will das von mir?
Also, ich habe hier eine CSV-Datei.
Und die muss ich in die Clickhouse-Datenbank packen.
Also in die Tabelle HTTP-Requests in der Monitoring-Database.
Okay, das wird jetzt spannend.
Habe ich noch nie benutzt.
Und nie benutzt Clickhouse.
Also, bam.
Also, ich habe hier angeblich eine Data Request CSV liegen.
Okay.
Und was soll ich genau jetzt inserten?
Timestamp?
Oder ich soll eine Tabelle anlegen, die exakt den Kram hat.
Timestamp, Service Name, Endpoint oder was?
jaja
heimstern service der endpoint methods status code latency latency ms region user user id
monka wl csv handling ist ja immer schlimm also test ist über able to
query the database and see the data gut ich kann nicht mal die database query
Woher weiß der überhaupt zu welcher Datenbank er sich connecten soll, by the way?
kubectl get pods-course a. Zack, Clickhouse, running, running, running. Also wir haben hier,
so wie es aussieht, vermutlich ein StatefulSet oder irgendwie sowas. Würde ich jetzt einfach
mal vermuten hat der benahmung hinten dran also es gibt drei klick haus datenbanken
ein klick haus operator gut der hier sieht uns wahrscheinlich jetzt weniger
und einen keeper klick haus
table may not exist in all pot instances weil ich die dann anlegen wenn die nicht wenn die nicht
existiert okay da machen jetzt erst mal port vorwürdig würde ich sagen wir kommen wir gucken
uns erst einmal diesen pott hier an. cubectl edit-namespace clickhouse und wir gucken uns
den einfach mal an. gucken uns mal die erste datenbank an. so was haben wir hier? also
ordentliches syntax highlighting hätten wir, sehr nice. welcher port ist das? 9000
und 8123.
Wahrscheinlich ist das hier
der Clickhouse
Port.
Nicht Clockhouse.
Okay, 8123 ist der richtige
Port, den wir haben wollen. Den müssen wir uns jetzt
forwarden.
Dass das funktioniert.
Okay, probieren wir das mal.
Cube CTL
Port Forward.
boah, da muss ich mir die Syntax jetzt merken.
Hier, Ports.
Äh, machen wir mal Namespace.
Namespace, Clickhouse, ne?
So, G.
Clickhouse, 0, 0, 0.
Machen wir mal.
Und dann Port 8, 1, 2, 3.
8, 1, 2, 3. 8, 1, 2, 3 war es, ne?
Okay. Machen wir.
Äh, wir machen mal einen T-Mux.
Falls wir eins drauf haben. Haben wir nicht.
Haben wir Hutrechte.
Nice. Up, Install, T-Mux.
Falls wir dürfen. Mal gucken.
Wir dürfen.
Schon mal sehr nice.
T-Mux. Zack. Split.
Das ist, wo wir es davon haben, warum ich
West Herm mag. Jetzt habe ich kein T-Mux
in T-Mux. Ich habe quasi meinen West Herm hier
und meinen T-Mux auf dem Server da.
So. Da machen wir jetzt
erstmal ein Port Forwarding
in den
ClickhouseDB
Container 1.
Und dann führen wir mal
das Ding hier aus und gucken, ob da was passiert.
Passiert nix.
Woher weiß ich denn, gegen was der sich überhaupt connectet?
Gegen was connectet sich denn der Client standardmäßig?
Default?
Weil der geht ja schon mal nicht hier auf Localhost 8.1.2.3, so wie es aussieht.
Clickhouse-Client.
da bleibt uns nichts anderes
mal gucken
ob es da irgendeine Madpage oder so gibt
gibt es natürlich nicht
Clickhouse Client
minus Miss Help
geil
exzellentes Tool
wir fragen jetzt ZGPT geht schneller
Switch DB
Disconnects
in your command host die ford argument ist user not a database ja ich weiß aber wenn
h leer ist likely die ford ja aber da muss doch wissen wohin er sich korrekten soll laut doku
ist hallo klaus okay joggt ihn aber nicht der connected sich nicht gegen
local aus guck mal weil wenn ich da mal curl local haus kommen ob die vorbeute
vorbeugend geht das fonds ok
Vielleicht ist es auch ein anderer Port.
Port?
Aha.
Clickhouse Client uses Native Protocol and not HTTPS.
Okay.
Dann ist das zwar verkehrt.
Gucken wir nochmal kurz.
Cube CTL.
Get minus N.
Blickhaus.
Minus O.
Jammel.
Gucken wir mal kurz.
9.009 hätten wir zu bieten.
Oder 9.000.
Dann ist es wahrscheinlich 9.000.
Okay, machen wir Portfall-Boding 9.000.
9.000.
Zack, mal gucken, ob das jetzt funzt.
Nö.
Okay, ich bin offiziell
so doof mich hier zu port weiterleiten mein klick aus klein hatte keinen bock drauf
er macht doch was das einfach nur lahm gewesen okay also position position option default ist
not supported
ist das jetzt ein bug in der aufgabe oder was was ich beheben muss weil ich
sehe nirgendwo default außer passwort default was ist denn wenn ich hier
irgendwie was anderes reinschreibe.
Okay, der
nimmt das nicht.
Position Option Default
is not supported.
Okay, easy.
Easy clap.
Vielleicht hat
sich das geändert. Oder die Tabelle
gibt es da nicht. Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Also der nimmt
standardmäßig, ja hier sagt er ja,
Also das hier ist der Test
Ja
Und wenn der nicht geht
Ist
Die Tabelle wahrscheinlich nicht da
Würde ich jetzt mal vermuten
Dann machen wir mal einen anderen Pod
Und gucken ob da irgendwas da ist in der Richtung
So was haben wir, Clickhouse 1 haben wir noch
position option ist noch zu portals ok 2
ok das ist ein bug in der aufgabe
das ist ein bug in der aufgabe
Das ist zwar hier 1 zu 1 das
Aber
Warte mal, wir gucken mal kurz nach
Agent
Check SH, was der da am Ende überprüft
Clickhouse Client
Minus Minus Host IP
Minus Minus User
Minus Minus Password
Warte mal
Sollen wir mal ausprobieren
A-House ist minus H
Okay, das brauchen wir nicht
Aber minus minus User wäre vielleicht noch
Nicht schlecht
Ist dann hier
User Default
Der nimmt bestimmt
Der nimmt bestimmt hier
guck mal, der nimmt hier
minus, minus Passwort
minus Host
wir machen jetzt hier Localhost 9000
schreiben wir jetzt rein
äh
muss ich 1
ok, was?
Oder darf man da vielleicht gar kein Port angeben?
Aha.
Guck mal, das buggt, wenn man hier nichts angibt.
Die Aufgabe ist fehlerhaft.
Da muss ein Host rein.
Unown Table Expression Identifier.
Unowned Table. Okay, jetzt haben wir wenigstens
mal eine ordentliche Ausgabe.
Das heißt, das ist es nicht.
Gucken wir mal, ob es auf der Einser drauf ist.
Auf der Einser ist es drauf,
würde ich sagen.
Oder?
Nee, auf der Einser ist es auch nicht drauf.
Auf der Nuller?
Auf der Nuller, okay.
Auf der Nullerdatenbank ist die Tabelle drauf.
Gut. Das heißt, wir haben das richtige Port
weiterleitet port gefordert und jetzt müssen wir irgendwie gucken wie man mit diesem klick haus
klein die sachen die hier drin sind insert du bist in all port instances so kann klick haus klein
csv importieren klick aus klein zu import data from a csv file to the table table we
can pay your file directly to the klick haus client okay das machen wir jetzt also query
wollen wir jetzt?
Okay, erstmal gucken, ob das was wird,
Alter.
Insert into, wie heißt
das Ding? Monitor, ah, na gut,
das geht natürlich.
Monitoring HTTP Requests
Format CSV
und dann
pipen wir da rein,
Data, Request CSV.
Okay.
Okay, scheint zu funktionieren.
Ich würde sagen, wir haben es geschafft, oder?
Was sagt der Check?
No.
Wie? Warum nicht?
Warum sagt der Check no?
Wir haben doch alles richtig importiert.
Warum sagt er...
Aber die Tabelle gibt es nicht in allen Pods.
Ist die Aufgabe denn auch, die Tabelle anzulegen?
Do this instance in all Pod instances.
Ach so.
Das heißt, wo es das nicht gibt, muss ich das noch anlegen.
Okay, okay.
Geht das auch einfach so dann?
Ne, ne?
Das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert.
Ähm.
Okay.
Dann müssen wir das mal anders machen.
Kann man?
Oder mit den Keeper-Pots.
Davon habe ich absolut keinen Plan, wie das bei Clickhouse funktioniert.
Aber ich kann noch sagen
Create
Warte mal, warte mal, warte mal
Wir machen jetzt noch was anderes
Kann man sich da so verbinden mit, dass man was ausführen kann?
Also dass ich jetzt gerade kann
Select
Sternchen from
Geht das irgendwie so?
Oder ich sag
From Monitoring
Moni
Monitoring
Punkt
HTTP
Requests.
Hä?
Warum gibt es das nicht?
Achso, weil es das bei dem 1er
ja nicht gibt. Ja, logisch.
Weil ich
habe gedacht,
Wir könnten jetzt, gehen wir nochmal auf den Nuller.
Select Sternchen from Monitoring.
Monitoring.http requests.
Okay, Timestamp Service Endpoint, also genau das, wie das in der CSV drin steht.
Die Frage ist jetzt, wenn ich jetzt einfach sage,
Clickhouse Create Table in einem Zweier.
Hier.
Create.
Create Table.
Monitoring.
Ne.
Was ich?
Clickhouse Client Create Table.
Da muss man ja einen Namen noch angeben.
What?
Gibt es auch ein Example, was ich checke?
Create Table T1?
Ach, da muss man noch angeben.
Alter, was ist ich für das Funds in Clickhouse?
Kann ich nicht einfach...
Clickhouse Export Table?
im port geht das schon dass es raus aus export
Äh.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ich exportier die Tabelle jetzt einfach aus...
Der exportiert auch nur als CSV.
Export Table
von Clickhouse
and import again.
Irgendwie sowas.
Das ist Clickhouse.
Clickhouse
Keeper.
Was ist das? Kann man das damit irgendwie
synken?
ähm, ich hab noch eine andere Idee
Clickhouse
Import CSV
Create Table, falls es das nicht
gibt
Create Table, ah ja hier
Before importing
data, let's create a table
ja, ich weiß ja gar nicht mit was
die Table angelegt ist, das heißt
da muss ich bei der alten Tabelle nochmal
gucken
ähm
Clickhouse.
Ich habe den Kram noch nie verwendet.
Jetzt Schema
oder irgendwie sowas.
Information Schema.
Describe Table.
Describe?
Describe.
Table.
Monitoring.
Was?
Da ist es doch.
Ach so, http request, so muss ich gucken.
Aber warum geht das nicht?
Describe table monitoring?
Click house, describe table.
Ja, was weiß ich denn, wie das hier für uns funktioniert?
Describe Table.
Ja, nice. Super.
Eins, ich muss sagen,
Monitoring
HTTP
Requests
Achso, okay.
Ah, hier sieht man den Krempel jetzt.
Okay, gut.
Also, dann.
Meine Güte, du hast einen Ecker.
Zack.
So, jetzt kann ich mich connecten.
Und jetzt sagen wir, create.
Moment, ist das jetzt ein...
Monitoring Database.
Okay.
Create.
database
monitoring
all that exists, okay.
Create table
monitoring
.http requests
So, und da muss ich jetzt
gucken hier. Clickhouse
create table. Wie ist da die Syntax
jetzt?
Create table hat, wie gibt es da ein ordentliches
Beispiel für...
Okay.
Create Table. HTTP. Also.
Create Table. HTTP Requests.
Klammer auf.
UID
Int. Okay. Also im Prinzip
den... Wie? Ich kann den nicht scrollen?
Achso. Also im Prinzip
diesen Krempel von hier oben.
Aber das macht gerade hier so ein
Ding.
Dran, wo wir gucken können.
Na gut, das ist halt dumm. Das geht in KDE jetzt nicht richtig.
so also
create table
http requests
und nu muss dann da rein
timestamp
hey
wie sieht das aus
timestamp und dann was
date time
64 UTC
ah fuck alter
Das muss doch irgendwie besser gehen.
Service Name.
Muss man dann Komma danach machen?
String.
Endpoint.
Method.
Enum.
Alles klar.
Oh, guck mal, der kann sogar Syntax highlighten.
Status Code
UN16
Late C
Flow 32
Region
Low Cardinality String
Ja, natürlich, was sonst?
User ID
UUID
Ach, leck mich doch
Was?
Unknown Data Type Family String
Warum?
Ach, String muss groß geschrieben werden
Also überall, wo ich String geschrieben habe
ist es verkehrt string string sonst habe ich nichts mehr hat es funktioniert
ich glaube schon oder nicht das ist ja undurchsichtig
was primary key
What the fuck?
Wer hat sich denn das ausgedacht?
Ich weiß jetzt schon, dass ich Clickhouse
nicht verwenden werde.
Was will das denn von mir?
Weiß ich, was da geordert werden muss.
Order by name, length.
Order by
Timestamp.
Timestamp. Bam.
Hey, es hat funktioniert.
Nice, du. Ich copy-paste
mir das mal kurz.
Falls der gerade gleich den Server abschaltet.
CSV.
Bam.
So.
Bye.
Zack
Bam
Fertig
Tada
Was ein Echt man
Was ein
Eklige Aufgabe
Was eine
Eklige Aufgabe oder
Könnte man bestimmt viel einfacher lösen, wenn man Arno von Clickhouse hätte.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung von Clickhouse.
Aber richtig eklige Aufgabe.
Und jetzt kommt Zertifikatskacke.
Jawoll.
Eine Kackeaufgabe nach der nächsten.
Okay, machen wir das erste Mal.
Sollte er das jetzt nicht eigentlich abbauen?
Check my solution.
Ja.
Ich hoffe, er hat das jetzt abgebaut.
So, also, was haben wir jetzt als nächstes?
Campina Grande.
Give me my third vault.
Ah, wir machen Hesikor Vault-Stells.
Also, Web-Application läuft unter nginxexample.com.
und hat ein expired Certificate.
Ich soll ein neues Zertifikat
issuen
und zwar
soll ich mir das geben lassen vom
HashiCorp Vault, der auf diesem Server läuft.
So, die Vault Instance ist unsealed
and initialized
and you have full admin access
with the admin user.
Test running curl returns hello.
Certificate
presented by Nginx is issued by
wald pk check using okay ja ich habe ein blass ich kenne wollte ich habe wohl auch schon verwendet
aber ich habe keine ahnung mit dem kram kommando zeilentechnisch macht so next ssh sagt jetzt so
dann verifizieren wir erst einmal das köln selbst nicht funktioniert ja wohl funktioniert nicht so
gucken wir mal ob der nx auf an sich funktioniert ja macht also zertifikate abgelaufen so ich habe
absolut keine ahnung wie man das per volt macht hc co volt ist you news certificate
pki issue gibt es hier einen wald command wald wald wald pki
scheint schon mal richtig zu sein wald pki also ich darf da anscheinend auch darauf zugreifen
Ich darf da zugreifen, hab Admin Zugriff und alles.
ist also wald pk issue wahrscheinlich hier hast du es doch guck mal ach easy easy das
kriege ich auch so hin dann müssen wir jetzt erst einmal gucken wir hatten glaube ich sogar
das ssl kommando hier drin
also wir sollen ein zertifikat ist für
engine x example punkt com
also es heißt im endeffekt wir machen jetzt wollt pk ich jura name ist mir
Scheißegal.
Äh.
Kann man
nehmen? Aber
was sind denn diese komischen Dinger
hier hinten dran?
Geht das jetzt, wenn ich so mach?
Nö.
Ist das Auto
complete?
Vault
Completion
geht das?
Vault Completion Bash?
Äh, Tool ohne
Completion ist mir schon mal sehr suspekt.
Okay, da muss ich
Google danach.
Vault PKI? Gibt es da
sowas wie List?
Health Check PKI?
Okay, es ist anscheinend
irgendwas kaputt.
Vault, Secrets, List.
Ah!
PKI.
List PKI?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das mit Vault funktioniert.
Also hier, PKI.
Das heißt nicht PKI-Root, sondern nur PKI.
PKI.
PKI-Int does not exist.
Aha!
Ich habe ein Zertifikat, Leute.
Das war jetzt einfach nur krass geraten, ey.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich habe ein Zertifikat, das ist ja schön und gut.
Oh, fuck.
Ich kann...
Das ist ja schön und gut, aber...
Ich würde das gerne als Datei speichern.
Walt PKI Issue
Save as File
Was ist denn das hier
überhaupt? Was ist das hier?
PKI Int
parent child mount
the path of the
mount involved where the new
issuer is saved
also kann ich
muss ich dann quasi sagen pki
slash
äh
keckel oder was
ok keine ahnung
Ich mache einfach ein neues.
Aber wie speichere ich das denn jetzt als Datei ab?
Walt Wright PKE?
Walt Reed oder sowas vielleicht?
Keck Wade.
Walt Wright, Format, Jason?
What?
Alter!
Format? Jason?
Was?
Ich hab keinen Plan.
Volt?
Ich hab kein Base64.
Aber Format Jason?
What?
Was für Formate unterstützen das denn?
Wort? Format?
Ich will sowas wie
P12 oder so
Okay
Wir machen das nochmal neu, okay
Cute Chat issued
Das jetzt
Und jetzt nochmal Format gleich chasen
Was ist denn wenn ich Format leer lasse?
Juckt ihr nicht?
Okay.
Also hier haben wir die Sachen ja.
Certificate.
Begin Certificate.
Das ist die Chain.
Scheiß da mal drauf.
Certificate.
Und wo ist der...
Und wo ist der Private Key?
So funktioniert das schon mal nicht.
Vault, Generate, Nginx, Search.
Ein Blast schon mal noch nie gemacht.
Ey, das ist ja schon alles passiert.
What?
Alter, wie kompliziert kann man
bitte schon Zertifikatskrempel noch machen?
Jetzt hört man halt schon, Alter, wir haben ja
nur noch ein Kubernetes-Klass.
WTF, wie kompliziert ist das bitte schon?
Walt Wright?
Wie zum Teufel kommt man auf die Idee,
dass man Walt Wright machen muss?
Was?
Okay.
Nee, geht nicht.
Slash.
Da muss noch ein Slash hin.
Hä.
Alter, das soll mal einer checken, ja.
Was, die Rolle ist falsch?
Also hier muss Keckweh hin.
Anon Roll, Kekwe.
Anon Roll, Q-Champ.
Ach hier, Default muss da hin.
Ne.
Keine Ahnung.
Muss das da vielleicht weg?
Alter Leute, ich hab keine Ahnung davon.
Okay.
Wir fragen jetzt nochmal Chat-GPT, Alter.
Was das sein soll.
Das haben wir ja schon
Secret Tune
What the fuck
Was zum
PKI Root Generate
Internal
Ne, was haben wir denn vorher hier
Was haben wir denn hier vorher gemacht
PKI Assure Default
pki ist für die fault okay also die kdp
ist für die fault oder muss das flash
aus diesen irgendwelchen kunden auf
einmal nicht mehr hin und dann kann man
name ttl ttl kann man nehmen
kamen nehmen sollte nx oder sowas seine nx punkt example oder etwas gemacht
Leute.
Der hat was gemacht.
Aber wo ist denn der Private Key von dem Zertifikat?
Ich brauche einen Key
und ein Zertifikat.
war das also nx sampl.com
und channel generate internet das ist wie man wie man das nennen soll oder was gut
unsupported path
sich das wirklich so nennen
okay das hat funktioniert was auch immer ich da jetzt gemacht
habe absolut kein blassen schimmer wieder kein key
Was soll ich damit jetzt machen?
Ich habe jetzt
zwei Zertifikate auf einmal.
Vermutlich ist das das, was ich brauche.
Ne, also ganz ehrlich, wenn du keine Ahnung von Vault hast, hast du komplett verloren hier.
Oh, das ist ja auch Usability aus der Hölle, Mann.
Wer denkt sich denn sowas aus?
Aha.
Okay.
Anon Roll Engine X.
Generate a Certificate.
Create a Roll.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Roll.
PKI Roll Engine X.
Allow Domains.
Example.com.
Allow Subdomains too.
Okay, passt, habe ich gemacht.
und jetzt kann ich diesen Kram direkt in das Zertifikat schreiben.
Common Name,
Engine X,
okay,
anscheinend funktioniert.
Da muss man sich, glaube ich, einfach nur dran gewöhnen, dann geht das.
Engine X, Example.com, Key.
Okay, wunderbar.
Wir haben jetzt ein Key und ein Zertifikat.
Excellent.
Habe ich das richtig gemacht?
Das ist mit der richtigen...
xexample.com
Ja.
Zert gehört nicht zum Private Key.
Geil.
Also muss ich das machen.
Okay.
Einmal Zertifikat.
Alright.
PKI Issues.
Das heißt einfach Lulwe.
Ammon Name.
enginex example.com alt names ja meinetwegen cert jason geht nicht weil issue an die enginex
enginex
not allowed okay perfekt so ok enginex cert enginex key
what the hell nx nx key
was das schlimme so jetzt haben wir die hier die zwei sachen
private key zertifikat okay so sehr gut dann wollen wir mal etc engine x
sites enabled default so hier also etc engine x erstmal die mausunterstützung
ausschalten den BIM. etc. engine.x.ssl also cp home admin engine.x.sert nach ssl.sert.m
Ob das Format stimmt.
Key.
System CTL
Restart
Nginx.
Okay, curl.
Curl. Curl.
Kunst!
Alter, was ein Scheiß,
Mann!
Was ein Scheiß, Alter.
So sieht es halt aus, wenn man von den
zwei Sachen absolut keinen Schimmer hat,
die die hier wollen.
Wenn mich jetzt einer fragen würde, was ich gemacht habe,
ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich gemacht habe.
Ich habe gegoogelt und
ChatGPT gefragt, wie man Vault benutzt.
Und was ich in Vault nun wirklich
gemacht habe, keine Ahnung.
absolut keinen Plastenschimmer,
Leute.
Ich hab so
keinen Plan gehabt.
Okay, jetzt brauchen wir mal irgendwas, was
vielleicht nicht ganz so abartig ist.
Okay,
Chat, ihr könnt euch aussuchen
wieder
zwischen
35 und 45, die Sachen,
die wir noch nicht haben.
Oder keine Ahnung.
Wir machen was anderes. Wir scrollen mal woanders hin.
Hier. Ihr könnt euch aussuchen,
zwischen machen wir mal so zwischen 61 und 71 ok 63 bild kit und docker bild
mismatch noch jemand andere wünsche
Was habe ich da eigentlich in Vault jetzt gemacht?
6-7? Oh nein, hör mal bloß auf.
Das ist total out, ne?
Generation Alpha benutzt das schon gar nicht mehr.
Ihr könnt davon ausgehen, wenn so Sachen bei uns schon angekommen sind, dann ist das komplett out.
Gibt es noch was Schlimmeres als die Database Migration?
Die war gar nicht so schlimm, die Database Migration letztens.
Also das eben hat mich deutlich mehr abgefuckt mit Vault.
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt.
Wir machen jetzt Buildkit und Docker-Version-Mismatch.
Also es gibt eine Tiny-Container-App, Talin-Service.
Print-API-Version-String.
Das Container-Image wird gebildet hier raus im Docker-Builder.
Da liegt wahrscheinlich ein Docker-File rum.
Ich habe 10 PKI-Issuer angelegt, dann eine PKI-Rolle sowie 4 Serts, wobei nur eins richtig war.
aber es hat funktioniert am ende
Du wolltest legit
6-7 haben,
weil dich das Thema interessiert?
Krass. Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Ich hätte gedacht,
das ist jetzt wieder 6.7
oder
irgendwelche cringigen
Sachen.
Okay, dann
wollen wir doch mal Admin.
SSH, bam.
Yes.
Also, es gibt hier ein Docker-Bild.
Allen App. Guck mal mal
in das Docker.
Alter, Docker.
Ha, das dicker File, ja.
Das docker File, guck mal mal rein, was machen die denn da?
Talin Base, ganz schrecklich, dass defaultmäßig Maus-Selection im WIM eingeschaltet ist.
Talin Base Build, WorkDir Source, ok, Copy, Make File.
Das sieht das erste Mal nicht so schlimm aus.
wo ich mir bei diesem copy from null jetzt nicht sicher bin was das genau bedeutet ehrlich gesagt
so dachte dass das copy from null dachte ich ist eigentlich wenn man multistage bild macht aber es
gibt keine keine mehrere stages hier aber wir glauben den einfach mal das passt ok also das
dev team source api version and run a new build but qa still rejects the image tagged current
it reports 1.40 runtime okay fix the docker build outcome so the deploy image matches
what the source is also im endeffekt soll das ding bei der api nicht 1.40 ausgeben sondern 2.0
fixe image tag talent app current so die on disk contract file and the ship binary
monka s
so
etc italien app das kopiert der rein out
irgendwie erscheint mir das hier nicht richtig zu sein was die hier kopieren also schauen wir
mal hier was was steht denn da drin hat source api version 2.0 was haben wir dann sonst noch
talent service
Moment, was ist passiert?
Talin App Version gleich.
Sie ETC Talin
API Version?
Ne, das soll doch auch.
Okay, Talin Service.
Wo kommt denn dieses Service-File überhaupt her?
Copy from zero.
Bedeutet das aus dem Base-Image oder was?
Nee, hä?
Wo kommt denn das her?
Aus dem Base-Image.
Set Maus gleich 0.
Okay, dann machen wir mal eins.
Docker run
minus, wir führen das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Minus minus
rm.
Das da.
Okay, nice.
Out. Ne, gibt es doch gar nicht hier.
Das kommt nicht aus dem
Base-Image.
Das sind wie irgendwelche super
Docker-Magic-Sachen.
Was Makefine macht, das können wir uns gleich
angucken. Also hier ist jetzt schon mal nichts
Spannendes drin.
Was macht der denn hier?
Der mountet sich den Cache.
Target var cache talin cc.
Und dann macht er make install.
var cache
make install
Ja, das erzeugt wahrscheinlich dann
slash out.
wir machen jetzt mal ein docker
bild
mal gucken was der da macht
also
der copied
scripts und source
und dann macht er einen make install
wo ist denn das make file
ach hier ist das make file
make file also was
macht der hier output
ok da kommt der kram schon mal hin
ok ok ok
Out bin.
Talin Service.
Install.
Das ist ja eklig zu sehen.
Install Bundle.
Source API Version.
Jetzt, okay.
Vielleicht ist es viel einfacher, als ich mir das denke.
So, ich hätte jetzt eigentlich gedacht,
hier, Label Tali Api Version.
Schreiben wir einfach so rein.
Wir können ja mal, bevor wir es jetzt kaputt machen,
wenn wir 2.0 reinschreiben,
ETC Tali Api Version.
Okay, das kommt aus dem Make-File.
API-Version.
Da steht 2.0 drin.
Also ist das, was in diesem
Service
drin steht, falsch.
Ach, Moment, das ist ein Multistage-Bild.
Alter, bin ich dumm, ich hab's eben nicht gesehen.
Das ist ein Multistage-Bild.
Also das Make-Install erzeugt das hier.
Okay, passt mal auf.
Jetzt machen wir Trick 17.
Run.
Passt mal auf.
Das ist...
Wir fixen das jetzt so dirty,
das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen.
So, wir bilden das nochmal kurz.
Sollte jetzt nicht eigentlich was ausgehen?
Hallo?
Achso, da muss man das ausschalten
Ähm
Bildkit
Output
Wie war das?
Truncated
das muss man doch
Progress Plane
was, minus wie ist Progress?
Progress Plane, was, so?
Ja, genau, das suche ich hier.
Cached, geil!
Jetzt nächstes Mal Cached.
Also, da haben wir es doch.
Da steht
AP, hier Talin Version
AP Version
1.4.0. So, und jetzt
machen wir den dirtiesten Fix
überhaupt. Passt mal auf.
Ohne das eigentliche
Bild zu fixen.
Chat, ihr könnt darüber entscheiden,
ob das ein guter Fix ist oder nicht.
Ah.
Arlene, AP Version 2.0.
Easy.
Okay, und jetzt?
Soll ich das taggen als Current?
Okay, mach ich.
Äh, Build.
Minus Tag.
Zack.
Okay, geschafft.
Check my solution. Bam.
Easy.
Chat, was sagt ihr zu meiner Lösung?
Ist die...
Ist die gut
oder ist die
am Problem vorbei?
Ich meine, eigentlich
ist hier ein bisschen am Problem vorbei.
Weil
das Makefile
irgendwelche komischen Sachen macht, die es nicht machen soll.
Also eigentlich müssen wir
das Makefile fixen.
Aber man kann auch einfach
einen set-post-command ausführen und gut ist.
Lass mal kurz gucken, was es für Hinweise
gibt, wie wir es hätten richtig machen sollen.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Inspect the mismatch.
Haben wir komplett geskippt.
Rebuild and watch cache.
Haben wir nicht gemacht.
Read the build recipe.
The real bug is the dependency gap.
Haben wir nicht gemacht.
Haben wir auch nicht gemacht.
Okay, wir haben komplett an dem, wie der sich das vorgestellt hat, wie man es lösen soll, vorbeigebastelt.
Aber, aber easy, es funktioniert, ja.
Kein Problem.
Fixed, würde ich sagen.
Proper Cash.
Da hätten wir auch noch Makefile-Sachen fixen müssen.
Ich glaube, es geht los.
einfach einen
einfach einen Seed run und
fertig
äh nä
guck mal was ein Ak der macht
einfach
einen Post Command
Seed drüber jagen und gut ist
easy
so Leute jetzt ist es soweit
wir machen 6-7
Nee, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Also, Monte Video.
Was hat der denn damit zu tun?
Okay, also, auf dieser VM gibt es eine smalle App, die unter Slash Production läuft.
Nightly Snapshot Backups
landen unter Slash Snapshots
in ein Air Snapshot Style
Layout. Okay.
Es gibt jetzt allerdings einen Bug im
Snapshot Job.
Moment, das verstehe ich gerade nicht.
Was wollen die?
Was wollen die? Moment, Moment.
Okay, es gibt ein App unter Slash Production.
Es gibt Nightly Snapshots und Slash
Snapshots.
Jetzt gibt es einen Bug.
Im Snapshot Job.
Okay.
Das heißt, die Sachen unter Snapshot sind falsch.
Try Run Restore from Snapshot into Production.
If any Snapshot pass still alias is live data,
Restore would override production in place.
Ja.
Read backup notes.
Find every incorrectly shared
file between production
and snapshots daily.
Then repair the snapshots so it's safe
to restore.
Ich hab nicht verstanden, was sie genau wollen.
Das ist mir zu high IQ.
Okay, test.
Every file in diesem Snapshots
Verzeichnis
Ich check überhaupt nicht, was die wollen.
Wir gucken uns das mal an.
Vielleicht kommen wir da besser drauf, was da eigentlich angesagt ist.
Yes.
jetzt zu minus da wir sind gleich gut werden nicht immer klar gut also wir haben hier ist
production da läuft eine app und wir haben das ist ein users db sg light land ex gg
Set Servers Production User Database.
Excellent.
Und dann haben wir hier Slash Snapshots.
Und um diesen Daily Snapshot hier geht es.
Also Slash Snapshots.
Daily.
Und da gibt es.
AppConf, Inventory und DB.
Ja und wo ist das Problem?
Das sind keine Links.
Oder doch?
Oder sind das Hardlinks?
So richtig checken tue ich die Aufgabe gerade nicht, was die von mir wollen.
also das scheint ziemlich ziemlich sicher die die gleiche wir können das ja md5 summen
md5 summen aber hier app konf inventory db user db
jetzt war das ganze noch mal nach production
production production okay das sind exakt die kleinen erteilen wahrscheinlich sind das hart
links gehe ich jetzt einfach mal davon aus wie lässt man sich das eigentlich anzeigen
kann man sich hart links anzeigen lassen kennen wir die hard links bei er geht das irgendwie
überhaupt.
You can find
iNote number for your file.
Ah.
Okay, macht Sinn.
iNote number.
Aber das sind nicht die gleichen.
Ah, InventoryDB
ist ein Hardlink.
und
UsersDB ist ein Hardlink.
Dieser Fisch, moin!
Wir machen Linux-Bastelkram.
Guck, ich kann das ja mal versuchen,
kurz zu erklären.
Also hier hast du verschiedene Szenarien.
Bei jedem Szenario kriegst du einen kaputten Server.
Dann gibt es eine
Problembeschreibung und am Ende
also man muss das fixen,
was hier als Problem beschrieben wird.
Am Ende kann man dann sagen, jetzt check my solution
und dann sagt er, passt oder passt nicht.
Also wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, ist das Problem, dass InventoryDB und UsersDB Hardlinks sind.
AppConf ist okay.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Aber Hardlink bedeutet doch auch, wenn ich den hier lösche, was ist der Unterschied zu Simlink?
Simlink ist quasi eine Datei, wo drin steht, du bist eigentlich dort.
Hardlink ist auf Filesystem-Ebene der gleiche Einroth.
Das erkennst du so ohne weiteres gar nicht.
Wie?
Unlink Hardlink.
Gab's da nicht einen...
Probably unlinking Hardlinks.
Just delete the file name you don't want with the M.
Aha.
Okay.
Okay, easy.
Also kann ich im Endeffekt sagen,
Inventory DB
Inventory DB und was ist das gleiche gewesen?
Inventory DB und User DB, ne?
Hier.
Inventory DB 554
und User DB 553.
Also User DB, jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das stimmt.
Production ist immer noch alles da.
Okay, gut.
Also, AppConf ist schon was anderes.
Und was soll ich jetzt machen?
Achso, also das heißt, jetzt muss ich nochmal Production da
da rein kopieren nochmal
Inventory.db
User.db
Was so Sinn und Zweck der Sache ist.
Soll ich das so machen?
Keine Ahnung.
Ja.
Older Rotations must keep shared
config.ini.hardlinks
Okay, und da muss ich jetzt erst nochmal gucken.
Snapshot.
Äh, minus I.
Äh.
Chat.
Was habe ich getan?
Ach, ich habe LN gemacht.
Ich kack Noob.
Ich wollte LS machen.
Okay, ich habe nichts verkehrt gemacht.
Ist immer noch alles richtig.
Okay, immer noch alles gut.
Das ist der gleiche Hardlink. Ich habe LN anstatt LS gemacht.
MonkaS.
LN macht Softlinks.
Also, minus S, Softlinks.
Guck, da kannst du sagen, zum Beispiel,
guck, du hast hier eine Datei,
ja, und du kannst sagen, ich will diese Datei
softlinken, plopp,
lul, so, lul.lul,
Und dann siehst du hier, 0.0 zeigt auf Apple Conf.
Das ist quasi auf logischer Ebene oben drüber.
Hardlinks sind auf File System Ebene.
Das heißt, Hardlinks gehen auch nicht Mount-übergreifend.
Oder File System übergreifend.
So, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, haben wir es jetzt gefixt, oder?
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich es verstanden habe.
Check.sh.
Okay, easy.
Chat, geschafft.
Da sieht man mal wieder, man muss die Aufgabe nicht komplett verstanden haben, um sie zu lösen.
Next.
So, Chat, ihr dürft euch wieder was aussuchen.
Ja, zwischen 58 und 71.
Äh, warum?
69.
H-Top?
Okay, 69 machen wir.
Na gut, nachdem wir 67 haben, müssen wir jetzt 69 machen.
420 geht ja schlecht.
So viel haben die noch nicht.
Okay, run.
Also, auf dieser VM
gibt es
Valib Set Sysinfo TXT.
Okay, das Dashboard
zeigt Load an,
immer 0 und eine alte
Uptime,
while live process viewers
Es gibt ein Defunct Zombie Child Process.
Incident Notes.
Fix the exporter and the zombie lab.
So published metrics match the real kernel counters and all zombies will remain under the lab parent.
What the? Okay.
The first line of Sysinfo TXT.
Okay.
Alter.
Irgendwie ist mein Textverständnis
gerade nicht so
high IQ.
Ich glaube, ich habe es halbwegs gecheckt.
Also, die wollen
hier, also okay, Incident Notes.
Jetzt können wir erstmal reingucken.
Incident Notes.
sollen sie wissen das haben wir doch gerade tools eines haus gcc das bau mal gcc pro märz
er nett cat block also setzer info da laut ist immer null und abteil ist falsch ja kann
man hier auch ketten also abzeit ist verkehrt abzeiten seconds sollte dann
irgendwas um 60 oder karte sein gut das ist falsch ob set zombie c
rebuild after edarts moment wir sollen irgendwelche cc gedöns anpassen what
Moment.
Yes.
Da läuft doch überhaupt nichts in der Richtung.
Aber Moment, ich müsste vielleicht mal gut werden, ne?
Opt-Z Zombie Lab.
Und der hängt, oder wie?
Aber warum sollte ich das fixen?
Warum kann ich den nicht einfach abschießen?
Oder was macht der denn überhaupt?
Lass uns mal kurz hier in das
C-Programm reingucken
Int main
Der forkt
Wenn die Pit
Gleich 0, oh das ist Linux Magic
Und dann macht er
Eine Wildschleife, okay
Er wahrscheinlich legt es an dem Fork, oder?
Wenn die pitt gleich null ist heißt das der vorkann nicht geklappt oder wie
Org linux
Returns returns
Return
return value
Unsuccess, the pit of the child process is returned in the parent and zero is returned in the... was?
Okay, das heißt, er überprüft, ob der Fork geklappt hat.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Was genau wird von Fog?
Fork creates a new process.
Ja.
To distinguish between them,
the return value of Fork
differs. In original
process,
you can get the pit of the child process.
Okay.
Okay, okay. Also, das heißt,
der guckt, der child process
exited
und der
und
Und der Parent Process läuft...
Läuft weiter.
Der Parent Process hängt in der Endlosschleife, oder wie?
Okay, das ist mir nicht so ganz klar, was da passiert.
Aber warum kann ich denn jetzt...
Aber das Programm ist doch vollkommen useless.
Ich kann das doch einfach killen, oder?
Oder muss das weiterlaufen?
Steht das da irgendwie?
Ach nee.
Sad Zombie Lab is active and has no zombie children.
Okay, okay, okay.
Das muss...
Okay, ich muss tatsächlich...
Incident...
Ich muss tatsächlich den Kram fixen.
Okay, wir gucken mal.
System.tl. Status.
Lab.
Set.
Zombie Lab Service.
Restart.
Okay.
ja
woran sehe ich denn jetzt eigentlich dass es noch ein zombie prozess ist kann
ich damit mit hart ob gucken da müsste doch sonst irgendwie die
farm geht oder so dran stehen schon im
im im
im
hier. Das ist Z. Das ist
die, die fangt.
Ja, guck da.
Der da. Das ist das Problem.
So, wo lag das jetzt?
Ehrlich gesagt, check ich
das mit dem Fork nicht so ganz.
Aber ich glaube
mal,
steht es hier?
Ich glaube mal, dass dieser Check mit dem Exit hier irgendwie verkehrt ist.
Guck mal, ich sehe das so.
Der forkt, wenn die Pit gleich 0 ist.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, wenn der in dem...
Wenn das hier quasi...
Also an der Stelle ist es noch ein Prozess.
hier danach sind es zwei.
Und
der Child-Prozess
exited
dann und der Parent-Prozess
läuft weiter. Das heißt, im Endeffekt,
wenn ich einfach diesen
Camper hier rausschmeiße,
dann
so,
dann müsste
es eigentlich passen.
Oder ich returne anstatt zu exiten
Mal gucken
Ich kann auch theoretisch den
Ich kann auch den Fork komplett rausnehmen
Ich nehme einfach den Fork komplett raus
Der ist ja komplett sinnlos, der Fork
So, und jetzt
Und jetzt
Machen wir einfach hier wieder, zack
Status
Restart
PS
So, jetzt wird nichts mehr gezombiet
So, haben wir das schon mal gefixt.
Und als nächstes
ist diese Upload-Anzeige kaputt.
Okay.
Wie kriegen wir jetzt die Upload-Anzeige gefixt?
varlab set info.txt
Welches Programm updatet denn diesen Krempel überhaupt?
Fix der Exporter.
Welcher Exporter?
Set this info.
Ja.
Set Servers Philadelphia, Sysinfo.
Haben wir hier vielleicht ein, gucken wir mal.
Netznet.
Da Promptail und Gedöns.
Da irgendwas läuft.
Wir gucken mal rein.
OptZ, Sysinfo, Loop.sh.
Das ist, okay.
True.
OptZ, Sysinfo, Reporter.sh.
reporter.sh
Also was macht das Ding?
Das guckt.
Reads cached
Proc Snapshot
var lib set
proc uptime.
Ne, das ist ja nicht
der Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Der soll direkt
proc uptime, oder? Das ist doch das Problem.
Weil da wird ja nichts gecached.
Also im Endeffekt muss ich doch einfach nur
hier
den Kram rausnehmen.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Jetzt kann ich
das mal ausführen.
Hat funktioniert.
Und jetzt sollte eigentlich
in
dem was richtiges drinstehen.
Ja, passt doch.
Passt doch.
Guck jetzt.
Alle 10 Sekunden läuft das.
Müsste sich gleich wieder updaten.
Ja, passt doch.
Ist doch gut. Ist ja alles gefixt jetzt.
Okay, check.
Easy.
Lass uns mal nochmal die Lösung angucken.
Clue.
Das habe ich mir gar nicht angeschaut.
S-Trace.
Keine Ahnung, warum man es so kompliziert macht.
Hardtop haben wir geguckt, ja.
Das haben wir auch gemacht.
Den Restart-Set-Info muss man gar nicht machen,
weil das jedes Mal neu aufruft.
Fixed Zombie
Parent must wait.
Ich hab den Fork einfach komplett rausgeschmissen.
Okay.
Dann ist vielleicht nicht
im Sinne des Erfinders gewesen, wie ich das gefixt
hab, aber ich hab's gefixt.
Sehr schön. Next.
Chat. Weiter geht's.
Uh.
Okay.
Wir machen jetzt random, okay?
Chat, ich mache jetzt so, guck mal.
Ich mache jetzt die Augen zu und die ganze Zeit so.
Und ihr sagt Stopp, wobei ich sehe ja nicht, wenn ich die...
Okay, ich mache das so, dass ich nicht auf meinen zweiten Monitor gucke.
Ich gucke nur auf den Chat links, ja?
So.
Und wenn der Alfred Stop sagt, der Alfred muss Stop sagen, dann mache ich Stop.
Geil.
Schau mal, das funktioniert.
Okay, das war keine allzu gute Idee.
Mach mal nochmal.
Nochmal.
Sag Stopp, Alfred.
Okay, Florence.
Database Migration from Hell.
Das hatten wir schon gemacht.
Okay, dann machen wir das nicht.
Dann machen wir jetzt
Monaco Disappearing Trick.
Oh, das ist hart.
habe ich da habe ich da bock ja komm heck wo sind die hacker man's ja disappearing trick
an usual tricky hack peisen system d also es gibt einen web server
und ich muss die chat nachricht erstmal erlauben ich weiß nicht warum die geblockt wurde gerade
Ich habe eine witzige Geschichte aus der Elektrotechnik-Ecke.
Also ich habe mir ein schickes, portables, digital-analog-Konverter-Verstärker gekauft.
Und das hat ständig Störgeräusche gehabt.
Dachte es einfach kaputt, dann fiel mir auf, dass es immer nur spackt, wenn es in der Nähe meines Handys ist.
Der Verdacht fiel also auf ein EMI.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ein EMI ist.
auch irgendwie kein Wunder,
wenn man eine Glasscheibe über sensible
Op-Ams baut
und dann denkt das Ding
als Portabel, beziehungsweise
am Handy betrieben werden soll.
Titret, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung,
was du gerade geschrieben hast.
Als Lösung etwas von der
Eloxierung vom
ADO-Gehäuse abschmirgeln
und mit Kupferband
schön das Fenster zukleben,
um sein wahrhaft ghetto-mäßiges
EMI-Schild zu kreieren.
Alter, ich hab das null gecheckt, was du geschrieben hast.
Aber es klingt five-head.
Chat, Chat, Chat.
Bin ich zu dumm oder
ist das vielleicht doch nicht so easy?
Ich bin wahrscheinlich einfach nur zu dumm. Ihr habt das bestimmt alle direkt
gecheckt. Obviously.
alles komplett easy
in meiner abteilung ist es auch nicht da kann ich wenig zu sagen
ich habe zwar auch schon ein bisschen microcontroller elektronik gebastelt
gemacht.
Aber
dazu kenne ich mich nicht genug aus, dass ich
da irgendwas zu sagen könnte.
Also schön, dass du rausgekriegt hast, was das Problem ist.
Ja, das freut einen immer.
Aber ich bin zu dumm, überhaupt das Problem zu erfassen.
Also,
auf geht's es gibt ein web server auf port 5000 mit einer mit einem formular
ok wenn man per post request
ok wenn man das korrekte passwort über diese form postet dann kriegt man ein secret zurück
safety secret provided by the web page note the password you sent to it okay
da bin ich mal gespannt wir müssen rauskriegen wie das secret heißt
wir könnten auch cheaten wir setzen einfach einen grafikkarten cluster
drauf an, die MD5-Summe zu bruteforcen.
Das könnte dauern.
Moment.
Wir cheaten mal kurz.
Okay, es gibt
keiner, der das gepostet hat.
Das ist immer geistig voll anstrengend, ne?
Diese Challenge des Szenarios hier zu machen.
Da muss man sich voll konzentrieren.
Vor allem kommt da auch komplett random irgendwelches Zeug, von dem du gar keine Ahnung hast.
Hashi-Kob-Walt vorhin, ey, kein blassen Schimmer.
Ich weiß, für den Yolo-Fund war das easy.
Nee, das war nicht der Yolo-Fund.
Das war der Nex...
Moment. Wie heißt er?
Nex irgendwas?
Nextech.
Der hier der Vault-Checker war.
Ich habe euch beide verwechselt, weil ihr habt beide
bei mir fast das gleiche Grün
von dem Username.
Okay, also es gibt einen
Web-Server. Gucken wir mal.
Netzstat minus Tulben.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, Root-Rechte habe ich nicht.
Wäre auch ziemlich beklagt, wenn ich Root-Rechte hätte.
Moment, Moment. Wir können bescheißen.
Ah, okay. Es gibt kein Docker.
Das hätten wir bescheißen können.
Also, by the way, Chat.
Ich sage es nur nochmal.
Wenn ihr Docker-Access habt
als User, seid ihr
automatisch Root auf dem Server.
In der Regel.
Auch wenn ihr keine Solo-Rechte habt.
Vielleicht gibt es Podman.
Nee, gibt es auch nicht.
Also.
Aber nur bei Docker.
Bei Podman kommt ein bisschen drauf an, glaube ich, wie das gestartet wurde.
Ehrlich gesagt bin ich mir da nicht so sicher, wie das bei Podman ist.
Also wenn du Podman rootless laufen lässt, dann bist du auf jeden Fall safe.
Aber ansonsten...
Okay, hier.
Port 5000.
Curl.
Local host.
Port 5000.
Da gibt es eine Input-Form.
Input.
Passwort.
ID.
Name.
Passwort.
Okay.
Minus X.
Post.
Minus, minus Form?
Oh, wie? Moment.
Perl post form.
Weiß jemand nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Okay.
Ups.
Vercopy pasted.
Access denied.
D param value 1.
Also heißt im Endeffekt
Ich muss
Soll ich das jetzt richtig verstehen
Ich muss Passwort
Irgendwas
Posten
Ja
Immer Access denied
Ist das denn
All encoded
Method post
Was ist denn die Default-Methode?
Wie man
Default-Encoding
Form
Was macht denn HTML da?
Standardmäßig
Default-Encoding
X www.form.url.encoded
Okay
Dann mache ich das glaube ich richtig so, oder?
Password gleich Value 1
Okay
Nur mal den Klassiker probieren
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, ah geht nicht
Okay, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie rauskriegen
Was hier Sache ist
Gucken wir mal in die
Basher C rein, ob da irgendwas verdächtiges
drin ist
Ne, sieht nicht so aus
Hat der Webserver zufällig
Logfiles
Home Admin Web Server Pi.
Können wir das ausführen?
Hä?
Home Admin Web Server Pi?
Aber das liegt nicht bei mir im...
Hä?
Haben die das drüber gemountet, oder was?
Warum ist da ein Punkt Git? Gute Frage.
Aber es gibt schon mal keinen Home-Admin-Webserver.py bei mir.
Das ist schon mal hochgradig verdächtig.
So, als war das vorher mal da, wurde dann gelöscht oder irgendwie drüber gemountet oder so.
Es gibt ein Git-Verzeichnis.
Aha, ah, gucke mal da.
Webserver V1-Pi.
Git-Log.
First Draft, mehr gibt es da schon mal nicht.
untracked files hat denn vielleicht in ssh irgendeiner zeug gezeugt
authorized keys spannendes ok ok also heißt im endeffekt wir gucken mal jetzt show
Ne, warte mal wieder.
Das Git Checkout
Master
Web Server 1. Klingt das so?
Ja.
So, Web Server 1.
Da ist es.
Super Secret
Password. OS
Environment Get
Entered Password.
Ah, ich muss mir die Environment-Sachen anzeigen lassen.
Request.
Form.
Get Password.
Super Secret Password.
Kommt aus der Environment-Variable Super Secret Password.
If Entered Password Super Secret Password, dann Access Granted, Access Denied.
Okay.
Also.
Gucken wir mal, ob es da eine Environment-Variable gibt.
Okay, das gibt es hier schon immer nicht.
Was ist da sonst noch?
Aber mal was ganz was anderes.
Mal was ganz was anderes.
Return.
Okay, guck mal hier.
Das ist Version 1.
Das ist nicht die, die läuft.
Würde ich sagen.
Weil die
returnt ja angeblich irgendein Secret.
Die returnt ja irgendein Secret.
Sagt der hier.
Ja, das, das returned, das returned irgendein Secret.
Das heißt, das ist schon mal nicht das Richtige.
Schick im Post mal das Super Secret Passwort.
Ne, das ist ja eine Variable hier an der Stelle.
Die rät sich vom, vom, ne, ne.
Ich meine, wir können das mal probieren.
Einfach nur mal so just for fun, ja.
Aber das wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Ja.
Und was wahrscheinlich auch nicht funktionieren wird, ist...
What?
What the fuck?
Was wahrscheinlich auch nicht funktionieren wird, ist...
Super Secret Passwort.
Das wird auch nicht funktionieren.
Wir müssen irgendwie...
an...
An das Environment rankommen.
Von...
Von dem Webserver-Pi.
Hm.
Ja, wie kann man das machen?
Das ging doch irgendwie hier.
Get environment
variables
from process.
Pit of
Ah!
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Genau.
Ja.
Das ist das Passwort.
Secret ist
easy.
Wie kann da ein Web-Server laufen,
der überhaupt nicht existiert?
Der existierte.
Die Datei gab es.
Der hat den Web-Server gestartet
und danach die Datei gelöscht.
Also, welche Datei soll ich das jetzt reinschreiben?
My Solution.
X, X der Solution.
MD5 Sum.
Yep. Check my Solution.
Easy. Okay.
Das fand ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt einfacher
als die mittelste,
obwohl das eine schwere Aufgabe war,
fand ich deutlich einfacher
als die mittelschweren Aufgaben
mit Clickhouse, DB
und Vault.
Oder was sagt ihr?
Das war doch insgesamt einfacher.
Was trinken?
Kreative Aufgaben, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Okay, Chad, eine Aufgabe machen wir noch.
Eine Aufgabe.
Irgendwelche speziellen Vorlieben von euch.
Wobei, so genau will ich das gar nicht wissen.
Also, was die Aufgabe angeht.
Was?
Was, 55?
Optimize Portman Image.
Okay.
Das machen wir jetzt.
Initially the image size is 261 MB and contains 100 layers.
Optimize the image.
Local host brought latest.
So that its size is less than 240 MB.
Using the same tag.
Run a container named check from the optimized image.
So, curl 8888 returns 100 lines.
Okay.
Run.
Ja, wir haben vor zig Jahren schon mal alle Aufgaben durchgemacht.
Da gab es insgesamt irgendwie 35 oder so.
Mittlerweile haben die 120.
Wir haben es vorhin mal alles zusammengerechnet.
Wir haben genau 120 Aufgaben mittlerweile.
Und es ist glaube ich jetzt schon der dritte oder vierte Stream, den ich mache.
Und guck mal, wir haben immer noch bei weitem nicht alles.
Zack.
Yes.
Also, dann zeige ich mal her.
Podman Run.
macht das jetzt was
nicht minus die
schadet nichts wobei scheiße auf thema zu machen einfach nur zweiter ssh verbindung
easy hier oben allerdings sondern curl jack is already in use ach so ich deb man stop check
wir wollen minus minus am local host was muss man köln 8888 okay okay also da ist
am portman ist schon mal nichts kaputt docker image nicht docker hat man jetzt bin ich verwirrt
Hotman-Image
Local Host
Prot
Aber das
Okay, es ist Potman, das ist nicht
Okay, das ist 251
Wo wird denn das Image
gebildet? Steht da irgendwo was?
Wo hier
das Docker-File dafür ist?
Generate
.sh
What the fuck?
Was ist das denn hier für eine Abartigkeit?
Ich hab gedacht, da gibt's irgendwo
ein Docker-File oder sowas.
Generate.sh
Pod.tar
Was macht denn generate.sh?
In generate.
Okay, base image, engine x latest.
Create image.
Base image.
Build dir.
Container file.
Wo hat er das überhaupt her?
Start Container...
Ach hier erstellt er das Docker-File.
Create?
WTF? Was passiert da?
Warum wird hier eine Index-HTML erstellt?
Mit...
Mit Nullen.
Das kann schon mal weg.
Das braucht schon mal keiner.
Echo,
this is Layer 1.
User, share,
Engine X.
Ja, meinetwegen.
Das geht alles in die gleiche Datei.
Das ist ja komplett
komplett unsinnig.
Aber das verbrauche ich auf jeden Fall
schon mal nicht.
Also das können wir wegmachen.
Das macht ja gar keinen Sinn.
So, hier schreibt er...
Okay, das Reinschreiben macht ja schon noch irgendwie...
Generate Container File...
Alter, ist das das Einzige, was wir löschen müssen?
Dann sind wir unter 200 MB.
Generated Container File.
First few lines, build the image.
Naja, okay.
Generate.sh
Das kann man auf jeden Fall besser machen, ey.
Das kann man auf jeden Fall schöner machen, als das so zu bilden, ey.
Aber mal gucken, was da...
Ich meine, wir werden ja nicht dafür bezahlt, es schön zu machen, ja.
Weil allein schon für jede Zeile da ein extra Layer anliegen ist,
ist total hängen geblieben.
Taggt er das jetzt überhaupt richtig?
Okay.
Docker Images.
Hotman Images.
Okay.
Es soll unter 200 MB sein.
Ja, das ist ja easy as fuck gewesen jetzt.
Also da hätte man aber noch deutlich mehr verlangen können.
Als diese... Letztendlich mussten wir eine Zeile löschen, rebuilden und gut ist.
Aber ich glaube, das ist der hässlichste Weg bisher gewesen, den ich je gesehen habe,
einen Docker-File zu bauen.
Man hätte da so viel noch wegmachen können
Dieses ganze
Für jeden Eintrag
Da einen eigenen Layer aufmachen
Mit einem Run-Command
Hätte man einfach eine Index-HTML
Fertig gemacht und dann dahin kopiert
Aber ich meine, wie gesagt, wir werden ja nicht dafür bezahlt
Dass wir es schön machen, ja
Easy
Haben wir es geschafft
Chat
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart
ich geh jetzt erst nochmal Eis essen oder irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung.
Und
morgen früh bin ich wieder ganz normal
am Start aufwachen streamen. Wie gehabt.
Und ich würd sagen,
dann sehen wir uns morgen früh,
bis dann Leute,
macht's gut, see you.